alors bonjour bonjour à toutes et à tous
et merci d'avoir
vous allez voir ça va dépendre de vos
réactions à la première planche
non pas celle là la suivante
donc bonjour à toutes et à tous et merci
d'avoir ménagé ce temps des changes
comme le disait juste à l'instant je
vais commencer cette intervention alors
j'ai jamais été auditionné par votre
commission enfin j'ai déjà fréquenté un
tout petit peu les ors de la république
enfin exactement ces soucis puisque
j'avais eu le plaisir déjà d'échangés
avec la mission sur l'effet de serre qui
avaient été constituées par l'assemblée
nationale
avec jean yves le déaut et nathalie
kosciusko morizet donc c'était la
préhistoire
des auditions sur les questions de
changement climatique à l'assemblée
nationale
je vais aujourd'hui essayer de vous
montrer un certain nombre de choses
alors ou bien vous sauter en l'air à la
lecture de ce qui va suivre et j'ai
besoin de trois quarts d'heure pour vous
expliquer pourquoi c'est logique ou bien
on part de ça comme acquis et à ce
moment j'ai juste quelques éléments
complémentaires à vous montrer le
premier élément de conclusions
auxquelles j'ai envie de vous amener
c'est que sans énergie le monde moderne
n'existerait pas l'énergie a façonné la
totalité de ce qui nous entoure la
hausse du pouvoir d'achat l'urbanisation
la tertiarisation la mondialisation le
temps libre les retraites les études
longues les 35 heures le en gros la
totalité de ce qui aujourd'hui fait ce
qu'on considère être les acquis sociaux
que nous pensons éternelle c'est
l'énergie et il n'y a pas assez
d'énergie pour que le smicard français
continue à consommer comme ils
consomment il s'agit pas de vous et moi
qui sommes dans les catégories
supérieures il s'agit bien du smicard
français qui n'aura pas la possibilité
et ça a déjà commencé de continuer à
consommer comme ils consomment est toute
la question est de savoir comment est ce
que ce genre de situation se gère sans
que ça dégénère en instabilité sociale
très forte
la deuxième chose que je souhaite vous
dire c'est que en première approximation
j'ai de très belles courbes pour le
montrer le pib mondial ne dépend que de
l'énergie disponible
dit autrement
si l'énergie disponible se met à être
contrainte et il s'agit pas de prix il
s'agit de volume alors le pib se met à
être contraints et en fait c'est très
exactement la raison pour laquelle
monsieur sarkozy s'est trompé quand il a
annoncé la hausse du pouvoir d'achat en
2007 et monsieur hollande s'est trompé
quand il a annoncé le retour de la
croissance en 2012 ils ont tous les deux
fait la même erreur ils ont pensé que
leur volonté était plus forte que la
physique malheureusement la physique est
plus forte que leur volonté et donc il
n'y aura plus de croissance à partir de
maintenant en europe en règle générale
on sera dans un monde sans croissance
une année sur deux la récession une
année sur deux un petit rebond
c'est tout simplement lié au fait que
l'approvisionnement énergétique en
europe est déjà contraint
je commence par la conclusion vous irez
si vous avez besoin d explication
intermédiaire
en europe à cause des contraintes qui
pèsent dès à présent sur
l'approvisionnement en gaz et en pétrole
qui représente en gros les deux tiers de
l'énergie consommée en europe et oui je
la présentation peut circuler ya pas de
problème et vous savez on retient 90% de
ce qu'on écrit et 10% de ce qu'on entend
il ya dès à présent en europe une
contraintes d'approvisionnement qui fait
insiste que la croissance perpétuelle ne
reviendra plus alors on peut trouver ça
attriste
désagréable c'est pourquoi mon sentiment
c'est que tout plan fait pour l'avenir
qui présuppose que l'on va financer
n'importe quoi avec les surplus d'une
croissance retrouvée fera faillite c'est
assez simple à partir de maintenant il
faut faire les plans pour l'avenir sans
croissance
voilà donc ça je viens de le dire de ce
fait le temps joue contre nous et de ce
fait il ya un effet d'éviction
absolument majeur dans le fait de
financer des trucs qui ne servent à rien
dit autrement tout truc qui sert à rien
engendre un effet d'éviction sur les
trucs qui pourrait servir à quelque
chose
et pour aller directement aux fruits de
ma pensée si on dépense des dizaines de
milliards en panneaux photovoltaïques et
ben c'est dizaines de milliards ne sont
plus disponibles pour faire des trucs
qui sert vraiment à quelque chose étant
donné que les panneaux photovoltaïques
porte sur des couilles m dans la
situation actuelle
on ne peut pas compter sur la limitation
de l'énergie fossile disponibles dont
qui autrement on peut plus habiller paul
sans déshabiller jacques voilà c'est
l'approché de la caractéristique un
univers sans croissance
vous n'avez vous avez on est dans une
mauvaise situation en terme d'échelle de
temps c'est à dire qu'il ya trop
d'énergie fossile sur cette terre pour
compter sur sa limitation pour sauver le
climat mais il y en a déjà plus assez
pour compter sur son abondance pour
faire redémarrer l'économie européenne
peut répéter si vous voulez
dit autrement
dit autrement il va falloir que l'europe
trouve le moyen avec une économie sans
croissance d'inciter les gens qui ont
plein de charbon à ne pas taper dedans
voilà je vous rappelle que nos voisins
allemands ont décidé de faire exactement
l'inversé pour le moment et enfin la
dernière chose le dernier élément de
conclusion c'est que bien évidemment la
hiérarchie des nuisances ou la
hiérarchie des mérites valable en monde
infini n'est pas celle qui est valable
en monde fini puisque
l'ordre respectif des contraintes que
l'on doit prendre en compte change
complètement
entre autres conclusions
ça implique aussi que les modèles
macroéconomiques que nous utilisons
aujourd'hui qui sont asservis par des
fins qui boucle par les prix et qui
présuppose d élasticité entre les prix
et les volumes qui sont à peu près
constante sont devenus grossièrement
inopérant c'est la raison pour laquelle
on a pas entre guillemets vu venir la
crise de 2007 qu'on pouvait très bien
voir venir si on se concentre sur les
volumes et notamment les volumes
d'énergie et qu'on ne voit pas venir si
on regarde les prix est l'une des choses
que je vous montrerai si j'en ai le
temps c'est qu'aujourd'hui par exemple
sur le pétrole il n'ya plus d'élasticité
prix volume c'est-à-dire que le prix du
pétrole ne donne pas la quantité de
pétrole il donne le prix points or ce
qui compte pour l'économie c'est la
quantité c'est pas le p
donc voilà les voilà les quelques
conclusions que je vous propose alors
maintenant il ya deux options non comme
des films vous pouvez choisir la fin ou
bien on part de ces choses là j'ai plus
rien à vous montrer et on discute ou
bien ça demande quand même quelques
explications et à ce moment je voulais
fourni
alors on va continuer et on va commencer
par des choses que vous avez sûrement
entendu qu'ils sont totalement
contradictoire avec ce que je viens de
vous raconter la première que vous avez
entendu et qui est vrai c'est que c'est
pas la peine de s'occuper du pétrole
parce qu'il ya de moins en moins de
pétrole dans le pib c'est tout à fait
vrai si vous regardez la quantité de
pétrole par euros de pib elle décroît la
deuxième chose que vous pourriez dire
c'est que hormis cas particulier de
précarité c'est pas la peine de
s'occuper du prix de l'énergie puisque
la part de l'énergie dans le budget des
ménages des croire depuis 35 ans fer
depuis 40 ans
l'énergie vaut aujourd'hui moins lourd
dans le budget des ménages qu'avant le
premier choc pétrolier donc on pourrait
très bien dire que mis à part quelques
personnes qui rouspète un peu c'est pas
un problème on pourrait dire aussi qu'il
ya plus en plus de pétrole de gaz et de
charbon extractible j'y reviendrai
vous l'avez sûrement entendu voilà ça
c'est très récent on va s'occuper du
climat en 2015 donc d'ici là c'est pas
la peine de s'exciter un autre truc que
vous avez aussi entendu c'est que le
progrès technique et de génie humain
résoudront tous les problèmes du reste
que avec des politiques courageuses
on peut faire exactement ce qu'on veut
et que c'est qu'une affaire de volonté
politique et moi je ne suis pas
complètement sûr que la physique soit
d'accord avec ça
on va revenir à la physique pour le
début de cette intervention pour
rappeler quelque chose que certains dans
cette salle connaissent probablement je
suis désolé ce que je vais dire
maintenant et probablement des redites
pour certains et des découvertes pour
d'autres je sais pas faire autrement
parce que le niveau de connaissances
préalables sur le sujet je vais traiter
est devenu très hétérogène donc c'est
très difficile de faire un truc qui
convienne à tout le monde donc je vais
simplement rappelé que l'énergie par
définition en physique caractérise le
changement d'état d'un système un
l'énergie avant d'être des
kilowattheures sur une facture
c'est une grandeur physique et c'est la
grandeur physique qui caractérise le
changement d'état d'un système donc elle
obéit à des lois
qui sont des vrais loi dit autrement qui
ne souffre pas d'exception
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire que
l'énergie caractérise de changement
d'état d'un système ça veut dire que dès
que le monde change de l'énergie
intervient vous pouvez le voir dans un
certain nombre de modifications qui sont
courantes autour de vous par exemple un
changement de température fait
intervenir de l'énergie un changement de
vitesse fait intervenir de l'énergie dit
autrement vous ne pouvez pas faire
changer un objet de vitesse sans que de
l'énergie entrent en jeu vous ne pouvez
pas faire changer la forme d'un objet
sans que de l'énergie entrent en jeu
vous ne pouvez pas modifier une
composition chimique sans que de
l'énergie ans je vous ne pouvez pas
déplacer un corps dans un champ avec
lequel ils interagissent en queue de
l'énergie entrent en jeu vous ne pouvez
pas changer une composition atomique
sans que de l'énergie entrent en jeu et
vous ne pouvez pas faire interagir de la
matière et du rayonnement alors là je
vous ai montré la version agréable à
partir du 1er juillet il ya une version
plus courant de tous les jours c'est le
four à micro ondes à chaque fois de
l'énergie entrent en jeu dit autrement
là où l'économiste va mesurer la
transformation avec des euros de valeur
ajoutée du moins quand il s'agit d'une
activité économique des hommes le
physicien lui y verra des kilowattheures
pas de transformation 100 kilowatts
heure jamais du coup pas d'énergie
propre puisque l'énergie s'est
transformée et la transformation ne peut
pas être propre la propreté c'est
laisser les choses en l'état l'énergie
c'est fait pour ne pas laisser les
choses en l'état donc l'énergie propre
ça n'existe pas ce qui peut exister
c'est de l'énergie utilisée dans des
quantités tels que les avantages
surpasse les inconvénients ça oui
l'énergie propre ça n'existe pas en plus
verte que rose que violette à paillettes
du reste
ce que je vous ai dit tout à l'heure sur
le fait que l'énergie à structurer notre
monde moderne réside en totalité dans le
petit calcul d'ordre de grandeur que je
vais vous montrer maintenant
si on suppose qu'on transpose
l'hémicycle à chamonix et que vous
montez tous les matins sur le mont blanc
pour vous mettre en appétit
tous les matins c'est pas facile vous
allez voir ça fait pas beaucoup
d'énergie et bien en montant sur le mont
blanc
si je les fais bien longtemps en montant
sur le mont blanc est bien l'énergie
mécanique que vous allez restituer avec
vos jambes et de l'ordre d'un demi kilo
watt heure donc voyez ce qu'un être
humain peut fournir avec ses muscles en
une journée de transpiration assez
significative on est d'accord et bien
c'est de l'ordre d'un demi kilo watt
heure d'énergie mécanique si vous faites
intervenir vos bras vous êtes à dix fois
moins et le 10 fois moins c'est de
l'ordre de 5 mètres cubes de terre
remontée d'un mètre vous pouvez essayer
ça fait un bel exercice et de bell en
poule
dit autrement quelqu'un de très bien
entraînés qui est capable de faire ce
genre de plaisanterie un jour sur deux
et bien à la fin de l'année il aura été
capable de fournir avec ses muscles de
l'ordre de 100 kilowatts heure d'énergie
mécanique donc retourné cette
équivalence un être humain égale 100
kilowatts heure d'énergie mécanique
fourni en un an maximum maximorum
raisonnons un tout petit peu économie si
vous prenez pour ça quelqu'un qui est
payé au smic en france vous allez payer
votre kilowattheures d'énergie mécanique
quelques centaines à quelques milliers
d'euros
avant l'avènement de l'énergie fossile
la capacité de transformation du monde
des hommes valais entre guillemets des
centaines ou des milliers de fois plus
cher que ce que les machines nous
permettent de faire aujourd'hui
exactement alors prenons un esclave ce
qui est pas politiquement correct mais
ce qui a été un fait c'est moins cher
mais c'est quand même plus cher que
l'énergie c'est moins cher mais c'est
quand même plus cher que l'énergie il
faut il faut le il faut le nourrir il
faut les empêcher de mourir il faut
l'acheter et sert à rien que ça ça vous
coûte quelques euros par jour
le salariat découle de l'énergie
abondante sans énergie abondante on aura
de nouveau des tensions sociales très
fortes dans un litre d'essence vous avez
de l'ordre de 10 kilowatts heure
d'énergie ce qui veut dire que ça vous
permet d'avoir de l'énergie mécanique
pour 1000 à 10000 fois moins cher que le
coût du travail en occident tout réside
là dedans la hausse du pouvoir d'achat
l'industrialisation etc etc et y compris
aussi la tertiarisation des emplois ce
que je vais vous montrer après voilà
comment a évolué la quantité d'énergie
consommée par personne à la surface de
la planète depuis un siècle et demi vous
voyez que en 1860 le terrien ordinaire
il avait à peu près 1500 kilowattheures
d'énergie par an c'était surtout de
l'énergie thermique charbon il ya les
charbons et bois pardon donc ça lui
servait à se chauffer un peu au début de
la métallurgie un peu au début des
transports bateau à vapeur train et puis
au fil du temps cette quantité d'énergie
est progressivement monté à 20000
kilowatts heure par personne et par an
extraite de l'environnement dans lequel
vous voyez petits tas que le charbon
n'est jamais décrue le charbon reste une
énergie très consommés par personne dans
le monde et on verra après pour quoi et
aucune énergie dans l'acadie baliser une
autre de manière massive
aucune le pétrole est nu sera ajouté sur
le charbon le gaz sur le pétrole et le
charbon et ses skis excitant nos amis
journalistes là vous savez l'éolien le
biogaz le photovoltaïque la géothermie
etc c'est le petit machin bleus que vous
avez tout en haut et sarlat
d'accord
donc mais vous verrez après donc le donc
pour le moment on parle de trombone pour
le moment on parle de trombone il est
non non non non non non non non non
parce que c'est très partagé cette
affaire là c'est c'est assez indépendant
de la couleur politique donc le on parle
d'un sujet sérieux s'il vous plaît donc
quelques pourcents de décroissance par
an
le nucléaire c'est un plus gros machin
quelques pourcents de décroissance
et pour répondre directement à cette
question si vous pensez que ça ça jouera
jamais aucun rôle alors le lait nombre
font que ça sans jouer encore moins
quelques pourcents de décroissance de
south apparent
s'il vous plaît l'énergie c'est direct
de troyes en un donc quelques pourcents
de décroissance de ça ça ou ça parents
auront énormément de mal à être
compensée par la croissance de ce truc a
énormément c'est une affaire de règle de
trois
alors pourquoi est-ce que le charbon n'a
jamais décrits dans le monde tout
simplement parce que les deux tiers du
charbon mondial aujourd'hui servent à
produire de l'électricité et vous verrez
un peu plus tard que le premier mode de
production d'électricité dans le monde
c'est le charbon il faut savoir qu'une
centrale électrique 1 85 % de
l'électricité mondiale est fait en
faisant bouillir de l'eau donc ces
débrouillards compliqué les centrales
électriques et on peut faire la chaleur
soit avec du charbon soit avec du gaz
chaud avec du pétrole soit dur avec de
l'uranium à chaque fois vous faites de
la chaleur fait bouillir de l'eau fait
de la vapeur vous attaquent une turbine
sur paris et dans tous les cas de figure
vous avez besoin d'une source froide
puisque vous avez une machine de carnot
chaque fois donc les deux tiers du
charbon mondial c'est d'électricité le
pétrole c'est l'énergie des transports
et donc c'est pas le même usage que
l'électricité ce que vous voyez ici est
retenu ce pourcentage parce que ça
explique ramon lien énergie pib est
pourquoi à partir de maintenant il y
aura plus de croissance plus de 25% sur
l'approvisionnement énergétique par
personne pendant plus d'un siècle
pendant lequel nous avons structuré les
infrastructures les villes changer
l'agriculture fait les industries etc un
bâti les systèmes sociaux qui vont
dessus plus de 25 % par an depuis 1980
cacahuètes et en fait l'essentiel de la
hausse c'est le charbon et c'est la
chine si j'enlève le charbon en chine
pour le reste du monde c'est zéro donc
depuis 1981
hormis chine l'approvisionnement
énergétique par personne n'augmente plus
et en fait ce qu'on n'a pas vu parce
qu'on ne regarde que les prix c'est que
les chocs pétroliers ont marqué une
rupture de pente massive sur
l'approvisionnement énergétique par
personne qui a commencé a totalement
chamboulé le système économique mondial
en faisant apparaître le chômage
l'endettement et un certain nombre de
propos de problème qui n'existait pas
avant 1974 c'est pas une affaire de prix
vous aller voir après c'est une affaire
de volume
il n'en reste pas moins qu'aujourd'hui
chaque terrien dispose de l'équivalent
de 200 esclaves par personne c'est ça
que nous a procuré l'énergie abondante
et à bas prix
dit autrement si nous n'avions pas les
énergies fossiles on devrait avoir 200
planète terre supplémentaires dans le
système solaire ou sur chacune de ces
planètes terre 7 milliards de bons
hommes pédalerez comme des fous toute la
journée et ça nous permettrait à nous
terriens de vivre comme nous vivons
aujourd'hui donc les terriens
d'aujourd'hui sont assez comparables aux
citoyens de l'ancienne grèce vous savez
il y en avait un tout petit nombre là
c'est ce dont on se souvient avec une
armée de paysans qui était en train de
d'esclaves et de paysans qui était en
train de trimer pour eux et qu'ils
avaient pas du tout les droits
électifs etc voilà c'est exactement
pareil en fait la raison pour laquelle
on peut se consacrer aux affaires
publiques avoir le droit de vote etc
c'est parce que l'énergie à remplacer la
force de nos muscles et on n'est pas
obligé de passé notre journée à faire
pousser les patates
alors par dessus ça on a évidemment eu
une croissance démographique très forte
au moment où l'humanité sédentarisent on
est à peu près quelques millions donc la
moitié de la population francilienne au
moment où naît la civilisation
industrielle un demi milliard est
aujourd'hui en deux siècles huit
générations rien du tout à l'échelle de
l'histoire humaine huit générations rien
quatre fois passé de grands parents et
petits fils 1 4 fois et bien on est
passé à 7 milliards et ça continue
d'augmenter et du coup bien évidemment
la consommation globale d'énergie a
explosé 80% de cette consommation sur
terre et le fait de combustibles
fossiles c'est à dire que c'est les
restes de vie ancienne fougères au
carbonifère pour le charbon 300 millions
d'années algues et plantons pour le gaz
et le pétrole
même l'électricité est massivement
fossiles vous avez ici la production
électrique mondiale en 1973 et en 2007
exprimées en milliards de kilowattheure
électrique donc hanter water milliards
de kilowattheures alors pour mémoire la
production française aujourd'hui c'est
550 térawattheures la consommation
électrique mondiale en 1945 c'était six
ans donc l'électricité c'est vraiment le
fait de la deuxième moitié du 20e siècle
1 c'est une énergie qui n'existait pas
avant ce que vous voyez c'est qu'en 1973
les combustibles fossiles font les trois
quarts de la production électrique en
2007 ils en font les deux tiers ce qui a
le plus augmenté dans le monde depuis
c'est le charbon est de très loin la
chine installe aujourd'hui une tranche à
charbon par semaine une tranche à
charbon par semaine ça fait un peu moins
une pagination dans le journal français
que les quelques fois où il achète un
rpr une tranche à charbon par semaine en
chine les capacités installées
aujourd'hui dans le monde les premières
d'entre elles c'est du charbon et entre
150 et 200 gigawatts de centrales à
charbon en construction en ce moment
alors à laquelle je vous parle sachant
que les capacités installées en france
sont de l'ordre de 100 tous modes de
productions confondues vous voyez que
derrière ce qui a le plus augmenté c'est
le gaz est seulement derrière vous avez
l'hydro électricité nucléaire
alors il ya aussi des énergies
renouvelables dans le monde je vous le
disais la première d'entre elles rareté
une règle du pouce qui marche très bien
c'est que l'importance des énergies
renouvelables dans le monde est
inversement proportionnelle à leur
pagination dans journal français
ça marche très très bien
10%
vous parle du journal français
10% de l'énergie mondiale provient du
bois qui est en fait dès à présent plus
totalement renouvelable puisqu'une
partie du bois énergie consommée dans le
monde correspond à de la recherche de
bois de feu autour des villes africaines
et ça ça engendre la déforestation
ensuite arrive l'hydroélectricité qui
représente aujourd'hui l'essentiel des
capacités d'énergie renouvelable en
construction dans le monde loin devant
l'éolien est ensuite arrivé au lien
qu'il a avec la convention la plus
favorable que je puisse utiliser c'est à
dire l'équivalent primaire vous donne un
peu moins de 1 % de l'énergie mondiale
les agrocarburants c'est 0 4% retenu
pour mémoire qu'avec cette unité le
pétrole ça fait 4000 donc dans le même
temps que le monde consomme quatre mille
millions de tonnes devraient pétrole ont
fait 60 millions de tonnes
d'agrocarburants 1 5% des carburants
mondiaux et pour ça les américains
utilisent déjà 40% de leur maïs c'est à
dire la même chose que ce qui donne aux
animaux aux animaux 1 40 % du maïs
américain
va dans l'alimentation animale 40% dans
les agrocarburants en allemagne vous
avez déjà des producteurs de maïs qui
mettent leur maïs directement dans les
méthaniseurs donc ça ne passe plus par
la case alimentation pour favoriser la
production de biogaz qui ensuite
favorisera l'électricité donc
l'utilisation de la biomasse on y
reviendra après au moment des questions
j'imagine à des fins énergétiques c'est
un truc qui ce qui doit se regarder de
manière un peu précises on peut pas dire
biomasse solution miracle et enfin le
photovoltaïque aujourd'hui ça fait 0,1
pour cent de la production électro
énergétique pardon mondiale pas
électrique et c'est toujours pareil
c'est mon problème de pourcentage est de
règle de 3 à quelle vitesse est ce que
ce truc là droit croître pour compenser
de manière significative
un déclin de 2 ou 3 % sur un truc qui
fait un tiers de l'approvisionnement
énergétique mondial c'est juste après le
de règle de trois
voilà ici l'approvisionnement alors non
pas primaire c'est-à-dire non pas
l'énergie qu'on retire de
l'environnement parce qu'il faut savoir
un truc avec l'énergie c'est que à cause
d'une loi physique qui s'appelle la loi
de conservation tout ce que les hommes
peuvent faire c'est d'extraire de
l'environnement une énergie qui s'y
trouvent déjà le terme production
d'énergie est un terme impropre
c'est une violation de la physique tout
ce que les hommes s'affairent sait
extraire de l'environnement une énergie
qui s'y trouvent déjà alors qu'est ce
qu'on trouve dans l'environnement des
trucs qui brûlent des noyaux d'uranium
qui se casse en deux de l'eau qui tombe
du vent qui souffle du rayonnement qui
arrive on ne trouve pas d'électricité du
moins tant qu'on sait pas brancher les
cafetières sur les éclairs d'orage on ne
trouve pas d'hydrogène corps pas natifs
il y en a plein dans l'eau mais il faut
plein d'énergie pour le dissocier de
l'oxygène donc tout ce que vous trouvez
dans l'environnement c'est de l'énergie
dite primaire et vous allez l'extraire
l'a transformée avec un système
énergétique et en faire de l'énergie
finale c'est celle qu'on utilise nous
carburant qui rentre dans les voitures
l'électricité qui alimente les
cafetières etc vous avez ici la
répartition de l'énergie finale
consommée en france en milliards de
kilowattheures par secteur et par
énergie finale tout ce qui est cerclé en
bleu l'asse des combustibles fossiles
donc voyez la france n'est pas un pays
tout nucléaire c'est un pays avant tout
fossile si on regarde l'énergie finale
exactement comme nos voisins européens
l'électricité est essentiellement
tout-nucléaire société oui l'énergie non
alors les journalistes sont souvent la
confusion entre les deux parce que on
aime bien parler de ce qu'on voit et en
france qu'on voit c'est des centrales et
oui qu'on voit pas de puits de pétrole
on voit pas de puits de gaz on voit on
voit essentiel on voit quelques barrages
donc on parle de ce convoi mais
l'essentiel de l'énergie que nous
utilisons vient d'ailleurs et donc le
journaliste français il n'est pas
focalisé dessus
en ce qui concerne l'électricité retenez
aussi quelque chose qui est important
pour les politiques publiques c'est que
l'essentiel de l'utilisation
d'électricité n'est pas un zonage
thermique c'est un usage du spécifique
c'est à dire que ça alimente des tas
d'appareils qui ne servent pas à
produire de la chaleur des frigos des
pompes des lave-linge et lave-vaisselle
des ascenseurs etc et
économiser de l'énergie dans ses usages
là c'est quelque chose qui est plus
compliqué que d'en économiser dans la
chaleur
on a aussi des énergies renouvelables en
france et dont la hiérarchie est très
exactement celle qu'on a dans le monde
arrive en premier le bois puis en
deuxième l'hydroélectricité puis ensuite
des tas de bricoles et vous avez ici là
l'éolien qui fait sauf erreur de ma part
5 % 2 7% et le photovoltaïque qui est là
qui fait non pardon il est là il fait 1
% de 7%
renom volume vous avez ici le taux de
croissance de la consommation
énergétique mondiale depuis 1945 je
voulais séparé en deux morceaux entre
1945 et le premier choc pétrolier vous
voyez que l'énergie mondiale augmente en
moyenne sur la période 2 5% et là vous
avez l'augmentation moyenne sur la
période après le choc pétrolier et vous
voyez ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure la descente très forte de ce
taux de croissance et si vous faites une
courbe de tendance sur ce taux de
croissance vous voyez qu elle est
négative donc pour ceux à qui ça dit
quelque chose la dérivée seconde est
négative et donc il suffit d'attendre et
ce taux de croissance deviendra nul ou
négatif un taux de croissance négatif
s'appelle une diminution
avant de vous dire quelle conclusion ça
m'inspire revenons à la manière dont
l'énergie à structurer les métiers parce
que ça c'est pareil l'un des trucs qui
compte en démocratie c'est d'avoir un
emploi
les grands maîtres penseurs le disait
déjà il ya quasiment deux siècles
l'énergie a totalement déplacé la
structure des métiers vous avez ici
l'évolution de l'emploi en france depuis
deux siècles alors voyez il ya deux
siècles le français ordinaires et des
paysans d'accord tout le monde avec
comme fonction productive première de se
nourrir lui plus nourrir 0,2 perd 0,25
personnes pardon qui n'était pas dans
les champs les deux tiers de la
population active dans les champs ça
veut dire que en moyenne chaque personne
se nourrit lui +0 5 personnes qu'il n'y
ait pas
d'accord
arrive l'énergie l'énergie permet de
fabriquer des machines qui vont rendre
service aux paysans des charreaux le
plus efficace et c'est ça permet de
fabriquer des moissonneuses batteuses ça
permet d'augmenter les rendements bien
jouer on va mettre les machines
directement dans les champs après guerre
ça s'appelle les tracteurs un tracteur
c'est 1000 paires de jambes un tracteur
200 chevaux c'est à peu près 1000 paires
de jambes en puissance développée et
donc un paysan maintenant il nourrit lui
plus 50 autres personnes alors qu'il
nourrissait avant lui +0 5 personnes il
nourrit lui puis 50 autres personnes
c'est 50 autres personnes pas se mettre
à faire autre chose grâce à l'énergie
qui permet de transformer des tas
d'autres ressources que nous trouvons
dans l'environnement des minerais du
bois des sols etc et on va donc se
mettre à développer l'industrie qui
n'est rien d'autre que de la
transformation de ressources naturelles
tous les objets que vous avez dans cette
salle c'est des ressources transformer
tous n'a pas un qui échappent à cette
règle donc l'industrie prend des
ressources gratuites dans notre système
économique et les transforme pour en
faire autre chose
arrive le choc pétrolier et à ce moment
le flux global d'énergies est ce que je
suis en train de vous décrire la s'est
produit dans tous les pays occidentaux
au même moment tous d'accord c'est donc
que c'est pas l'incurie du politique du
pays à qui fait que la situation se
présente comme elle se présente c'est
vraiment un fait physique globale dans
tous les pays à ce moment la
productivité par personne ne va se met à
aller plus vite que le flux global
contraint par l'énergie globale et à ce
moment-là part de l'emploi industriel
baisse
avec soit dit en passant une subtilité
de nomenclature parce que si vous prenez
un ouvrier dans une usine automobile il
est dans l'industrie si vous prenez un
garagiste sous un pont levant réparant
une voiture qui fait physiquement
exactement les mêmes gestes vous allez
le mettre dans les services donc
aujourd'hui la question de savoir qu'est
ce qui est de l'industrie et qu'est ce
qui est des services est devenue une
question ça peut vous paraître trivial
mais qui est en fait une vraie question
est quand vous parlez à monsieur pépy
vous dis moi je suis un industriel et
quand vous regardez ce que c'est qu'un
train et un atelier de maintenance il a
raison
l'insee le met dans les services quand
mon charcutier fait son bout d'un
excellent au demeurant chez lui il est
dans les services quand un ouvrier de
chez doux découpe des poulets dans une
usine il est dans l'industrie
discuter de la pertinence de cette
nomenclature pour savoir ce qu'on doit
faire plus tard fin de la parenthèse
donc toujours est il qu'avec la
nomenclature de l'insee vous voyez que
la part de l'emploi dans l'industrie se
met à baisser mais le flux industriels
continuent d'augmenter il a jamais été
aussi important qu'aujourd'hui et donc
les services où la productivité moindre
peuvent continuer d'augmenter derrière
c'est quoi les services et le commerce
c'est le fils la banque et puis c'est le
transport etc mais on voit également
apparaître une nouvelle catégorie qui
n'existait pas avant 74 et appelle les
chômeurs
les chômeurs c'est une manière
particulière dont le système physique
avec laquelle le système physique pardon
gère le fait que la productivité globale
du travail depuis ce plus augmenté aussi
vite qu'avant puisque la productivité du
travail c'est l'énergie qu'on a
donc ça ne peut plus augmenter aussi
vite qu'avant et à ce moment on voit
l'apparition de chômeurs avant 1974 il
ya un siècle il fallait plutôt passer
des lois pour éviter que les femmes les
enfants et les nourrissons on travaille
24 heures sur 24 donc l'élément limitant
avant 74 c'était le travail depuis 74
l'élément limitant n'est plus le travail
c'est l'énergie
voilà un instantané de ce que je vous ai
raconté pour la france et là c'est pour
le monde dont vous avez ici pour
l'ensemble des pays du monde je suis
désolé j'ai pas mis les étiquettes à
côté des points la consommation
d'énergie par personne en fonction de la
fraction de l'emploi dans l'agriculture
objectivement la fraction de l'emploi
dans l'agriculture en fonction de
l'énergie consommée par personne est ce
que vous voyez c'est que aujourd'hui
dans le monde plus on a d'énergie par
personne et moins vous avez d'emplois
dans l'agriculture c'est très exactement
ce que je vous ai montré en dynamique
tout à l'heure ces gens vont à ce moment
faire des emplois industriels et
services dans les villes donc
l'organisation
c'est l'énergie abondante
l'urbanisation c'est l'énergie abondante
le fait que la ville puisse être ainsi
un système socio économique stable en
univers énergétique très contraint avec
80% de la population dans c'est pas sûr
c'est pas sûr du tout et voilà un autre
truc qui devrait un peu vous perturbé
parce que moi ça m'a perturbé la
première fois que j'ai fait ça vous avez
ici les émissions de co2 par personne en
fonction de la part de l'emploi dans les
services
vous savez on dit toujours quand on met
des services ont dématérialise c'est
l'exact inverse on voit plus vous avez
de service dans l'économie en gros et
plus vous avez d'énergie fossile
consommée par personne alors c'est très
perturbant en fait c'est très logique
vous pouvez avoir tout le monde dans les
services à partir du moment où la
totalité de nos fonctions productives
sont assurés par des machines qui
consomment de l'énergie et à ce moment
les services qui consiste à gérer ces
flux physiques qu'est ce que c'est les
services égérie de l'information c'est
gérer des flux physiques et bien vous
pouvez mettre à peu près toute la
population active de dans mon sentiment
il ya des études qui commence à
illustrer ça c'est que dans un monde
contre un sur l'énergie la part du
travail manuel va augmenter et n'ont pas
baissé et la part des services va
baisser et n'ont pas augmenté enfin la
subtilité près que je vous ai exposé
tout à l'heure sur savoir ce qu'était de
l'industrie et des services
alors je crois vous avez aussi en charge
l'aménagement du territoire voilà
comment l'énergie abondante a déformé
l'occupation du territoire plus besoin
de personne dans les campagnes on a mis
des tracteurs tout le monde en ville et
on peut conserver la fonction des
changes des villes parce qu'une ville ça
sert à ça sert à une fonction des
changes en étalant les banlieues puisque
l'énergie abondante permet de garder des
flux en volume et en délais extrêmement
performant avec les gens de plus en plus
éloignés
le temps de déplacement peut être
conservée constant avec des voitures
pour tous alors que quand il fallait
marcher on faisait tous les commerces
sur le pont neuf et c'est comme ça que
c'était plus effi
vous voyez que l'évolution que je vous
montre ici a été vécu par tous les pays
occidentaux c'est pas le propre de la
france que je suis en train de vous
raconter la concentration urbaine et
l'étalement urbain c'est le fait de tous
les pays occidentaux alors quand on a
démarré les villes avant l'énergie
abondante les coeurs de ville sont
denses quand on a démarré atlanta déjà à
l'époque de l'énergie abondante ya pas
de coeur de ville si vous allez à
atlanta avec vous demandez au portier de
l'hôtel où se trouve le centre ville il
rigole parce qu'il sait pas où ça il n'y
a pas de centre ville ça n'existe pas
revoici maintenant une l'évolution de
l'énergie consommée dans le monde depuis
1965 mais cette fois ci je vous montre
ça sous un autre angle vous avez en bleu
les pays de l' ocde et vous voyez que
les pays de l' ocde sont déjà en
approvisionnement des croissants et ça
commence à décroître et ici vous avez
les pays dits émergents chez qui au
contraire l'approvisionnement continue à
croître et au sein de ces pays émergents
vous avez la chine où
l'approvisionnement croit extrêmement
fort maintenant regardons l'évolution du
pib de ces pays voilà le pib en dollars
constants des pays de l'osce et des
oeufs depuis 1960 et vous voyez qu'on
vit depuis 2007 et vous verrez après
pourquoi à cause du pétrole un épisode
inédit la croissance
la plus de croissance alors je sais pas
combien de temps ça va durer je vous ai
dit tout à l'heure je pense que ça va
durer un certain temps y'en a plus à
cause de raisons énergétiques par contre
chez les autres là ça continue voilà la
france c'est pareil plus de croissance
en monnaies constantes et c'est ce que
je vous ai tout à l'heure sarkozy a
promis un truc qui pouvait pas tenir
pour des raisons physiques et hollande a
promis un truc qui pourra pas tenir pour
des raisons physiques
eux ils font tous la même erreur dans
tous les pays occidentaux les
démocraties donc c'est pas alors voilà
le système économique sur lequel on
raisonne pour promettre la croissance du
pouvoir d'achat c'est le système
économique que vous avez appris à
l'école
le super quelque chose change en
fonction du contexte je vous précise que
je n'ai rien contre monsieur draghi ni
quand monsieur ayrault
à titre personnel donc voilà comment
s'organise le système économique telle
que nous la prenons à l'école vous avez
deux facteurs de production le capital
et le travail et donc si la production
n'est pas et s'est élevée pour payer les
retraites et assuré boucher le trou de
la sécu eh bien on dit qu'on va baisser
les charges sur le travail plus de
travail et on dit qu'on va baisser le
coût du capital plus de crédits plus et
cetera ça marche pas en ce moment le
capital est à coup négatif l'allemagne
emprunte à coût négatif et du travail on
à ne plus savoir qu'en faire on a plein
de chômeurs dans le pib augmente pas
donc c'est que ça marche pas comme ça en
fait ça marche de la manière suivante
physiquement l'économie n'est qu'une
énorme machine à transformer des
ressources naturelles gratuite et le
capital la formation de capital plus
exactement est une boucle internes au
système
l'immeuble dans lequel nous sommes qui
est un élément de capital ça n'est rien
d'autre que des ressources et du travail
passé c'est juste ça le brevet qu'un
industriel déposera aujourd'hui ça n'est
rien d'autre que des ressources et du
travail passé la marque d'une entreprise
achètera peut-être aujourd'hui c'est
rien d'autre que des ressources et du
travail passaient donc le capital c'est
des ressources et du travail passé et
l'économie n'est qu'une énorme machine à
transformer les ressources la
transformation je voulais dit tout à
l'heure c'est de l'énergie cette énergie
est fournie par un pour nos muscles par
200 pour l'énergie extra corporelle
alors une fois que vous avez ce schéma
en tête ce que je vous ai raconté
devient logique si vous avez un goulet
d'étranglement sur l'énergie quel que
soit le prix de l'énergie par ailleurs
si vous avez moins de kilowattheures
vous aurez moins de pib
quel que soit le prix de l'énergie une
illustration idiote si demain matin je
divise l'approvisionnement pétrolier de
la france par deux c'est caricatural
mais c'est pour vous faire bien
comprendre je peux garantir aux
camionneurs alors que le litre de gasoil
08 euros s'ils en ont deux fois moins
la machine économique française se
grippe
pas une affaire de prix faire quantité
le prix répondent aux quantités tant
qu'il n'y a pas de problème sur les
quantités quand il ya des problèmes sur
les quantités le système ne s'organise
plus comme sarah donc si vous surveillez
le prix vous aurez pas la quantité
si vous avez un problème sur les
ressources vous aurez aussi un prime sur
la production je prends un exemple idiot
que je prends souvent qui la pêche dans
la pêche le capital c'est votre bateau
le travail c'est votre marins ce que
vous pêchez c'est des poissons et
l'énergie c'est le gasoil que vous
mettez dans le bateau le pib c'est la
valeur des poissons pêchés donc temps
que le poisson est dans la mer sa valeur
dans sa contribution dans le pib 0 nul
d'accord c'est 15 milliards d'années
d'évolution qui a fait le patrimoine
génétique des poissons et qui a fait
l'océan qui permettent aux poissons
d'arrivée tout seul dans la mer sans
qu'on lui demande de rien gratuit ça
gratos pas un centime vous pêcher le
poisson donc il vous faut un bateau du
diesel amarin un poisson si vous n'avez
plus de diesel tu passes il ya un député
du guilvinec ici faire avancer le
chalutier du guilvinec avec les rames
compliqué
plus de diesel plus de poissons du pib
donc vous aurez beau marin votre travail
vous aurez votre capital votre bateau
pas de pib si vous avez votre marin
votre diesel votre bateau pas de poisson
pâtes pib
d'accord donc le système économique
aujourd'hui n'est encore une fois qu une
énorme machine à transformer des
ressources qui ne sont nulle part dans
les indicateurs économiques dont la
formation dont le coût de formation
n'est nulle part dans les indicateurs
économiques que nous utilisons en tant
que les ressources sont immenses par
rapport à notre activité c'est une bonne
convention l'approximation au premier
ordre quand le stock est immense et
notre prélèvements tout petit c'est pas
s'emmerder avec le niveau du stock mais
aujourd'hui notre activité est devenue
très significative par rapport au niveau
du stock et ne pas surveiller le niveau
du stock nous conduit à des erreurs
majeures
alors vous savez quand un ingénieur à
des théories fumeuses il faut qu il les
passe au banc d'essai vous avez ici un
graphique qui vous donne pour le monde
dans son ensemble la consommation
d'énergie depuis 1965 et la variation du
pib depuis 1965
d'aucuns voyant cette courbe avant
l'exposé qui a précédé pourrait me dire
ça ne dit pas oui la poule et l'oeuf ce
qui est tout à fait vrai par contre si
vous savez que le système s'organise
comme ça alors vous devez logiquement
trouver quelque chose comme ça
d'accord c'est logique c'est logique
voilà une autre manière de présenter la
même chose vous avez ici de 1965 à 2011
un point par année en abscisse vous avez
la consommation d'énergie mondiale en
ordonner vous avez le pib mondial
vous voyez dis moi combien d'énergie tu
consommes je te dirai qu'on mais tu fais
de pib
simple pour la peine de s'emmerder à
faire maison je sais pas quoi très
simple
par contre c'est pas une affaire de prix
vous avez ici le pib mondial en fonction
du prix du baril depuis 1960
pourquoi le prix du baril parce que les
trois quart du prix payé pour l'énergie
c'est du pétrole et par ailleurs le prix
du pétrole sauf le gaz aux etats-unis
pour les années récentes a servi le prix
des autres énergies il a servi le prix
du gaz dans toutes les autres régions du
monde il a servi de prix du charbon
vous voyez là dessus que de 1965 à ici
on est en 74 le prix du baril baisse
légèrement avec un pib qui monte depuis
le prix du baril augmente violemment
avec un pib qui monte puis baisse
violemment avec un pib qui monte puis le
pib montrent avec un prix du baril à peu
près constant puis le pib montrent avec
un prix du baril qui augmentent
fortement etc il n'y a pas de lien entre
le pib mondial et prix du baril il ya un
lien entre l'endettement français le
prix du baril que je vous montrerai
juste après mais il n'y a pas de lien
entre le pib mondial et le prix du baril
c'est juste un transfert de rente c'est
juste un transfert de rente d'accord
donc régler le problème énergétique en
attendant que le prix l'énergie monde
tout seul c'est accepter que la rente
parts chez les producteurs
d'hydrocarbures c'est juste ça c'est
juste ça d'accord évidemment nous ça
fera pas nos affaires alors voilà ce
qu'on paye au producteur d'hydrocarbures
depuis
20 ans il ya moins d'argent je vous
allez voir voilà ce qu'on paye au
producteur d'hydrocarbures depuis 20 ans
en milliards de dollars constants c'est
pour l'europe dans son ensemble
vous voyez que la facture pétrolière
européenne pétrogazière a été multipliée
en gros par 10 en l'espace d'une dizaine
d'années l'essentiel c'est du gaz un peu
du pétrole et vous savez probablement
que quand un pays un déficit commercial
structurel ça se traduit par une
augmentation de l'endettement on
emprunte l'argent qui sert à payer les
fournisseurs c'est exactement ça vous
avez ici un calcul qui a été fait ou
vous avez depuis 93 ici la facture
cumulée de pétrole et de gaz importé que
nous avons en france et ici l'aude
l'endettement l'augmentation de
l'endettement de l'état français vous
allez me dire la france est un pays
latin tenue n'importe comment avec des
pignoufs qui savent pas compter allons
voir un pays sérieux qui s'appelle
l'allemagne voilà l'histoire pour
l'allemagne
donc ce n'est pas une affaire de couleur
politique
ça serait simple si c'était une affaire
de couleur politique c'est une affaire
physique structurelles
pilotés par des systèmes dans lequel le
pas de tancer le demi siècle
autant vous dire qu'on n'est pas sorti
de l'auberge et je vais finir avec ça
puisque je vois que le temps s'écoule et
qu'il ya des impatients
pour vous dire pourquoi à partir de
maintenant on va être en récession de
manière structurelle je pense en europe
prenons le pib mondial que dans ma
grande sagesse je déclare égal à lui
même j'espère qu'on sera d'accord jusque
là
je vais multiplier
à droite est divisée par l'énergie et là
je fais apparaître un terme qui
s'appelle l'efficacité énergétique du
pib dit autrement c'est combien d'euros
de valeur ajoutée je peux créer avec un
kilowattheure de changements physiques
je change le monde ça a de la valeur
pour moi je transforme du minerai en
coûte aux jeux pourquoi je fais
n'importe quoi donc je change le monde
donc j'utilise de l'énergie aie ca de la
valeur pour moi et bien plus avec le
même changement physique j'ai créé de
valeur pour moi est plus mon économie
est efficace alors c'est ça le terme
efficacité énergétique de l'économie je
vais ramener ça aux individus donc le
pib par personne dit autrement les
revenus des gens ce que vous savez que
le pib par personne c'est l'erreur c'est
le revenu moyen par personne est
strictement égale strictement égal à
l'énergie par personne fois l'efficacité
énergétique
de l'économie de la la variation du pib
par personne est strictement égale
logarithmique mans et même la cédraie
variations de l'énergie par personne
plus la variation de l'efficacité
énergétique de l'économie
beaucoup plus simple que les grands
modèles macroéconomiques couple et dans
lesquels à part le type qui a fait le
modèle personne ne sait ce qu'il en
savait beaucoup plus sain
l'énergie mondiale je voulais dit tout à
l'heure plus de 25 % de croissance par
personne et par an avant 81 04 après
l'efficacité énergétique de l'économie
en moyenne mondiale un peu moins d'un
pour cent depuis soixante-dix et donc ma
théorie me dis que le pib mondial
devrait croître le pib mondial pib par
personne par don devrait croître de 3%
avant 80 en moyenne il doit croître
aujourd'hui de 1 % par an en moyenne
alors on va aller regarder ce que dit la
banque mondiale et la banque mondiale me
dit ça elle me dit que la variation
moyenne du pib par personne avant les
chocs pétroliers c'était 3 % par an et
que la variation moyenne du pib par
personne aujourd'hui c'est 1% par an et
donc je suis d'accord avec monsieur
vittori quand il dit dans les échos qu'à
partir de maintenant il faut que
l'assemblée nationale vote le budget
avec une croissance nulle
0,0
c'est avec ça qu'il faudrait alors
encore une fois que ce soit agréable ou
pas agréable c'est pas le sujet le sujet
c est ce que je me cale sur le monde tel
qu'il est où est ce que je fais un plan
pour le monde tel qu'il n'est pas et à
ce moment mon plan marchera pas
voilà pour la france
où vous avez ici la variation du pib par
personne n'envoyait de très belles
marches d'escalier et si j'avais le
temps je vous montrerai ça pour d'autres
pays ocde et ça marche extrêmement bien
eu deux ou trois trucs avant de finir
vous avez ici la même chose que ce que
je vous ai montré pour l'énergie mais
pour le pétrole vous avez en rouge la
variation de la production de pétrole
dans le monde il s'agit bien de volume
de barils 1 et en bleu la variation du
pib par personne dans le monde ce que
vous voyez c'est que l'asservissement et
très bon et non seulement il est très
bon mais sur les deux épisodes récents
c'est d'abord le pétrole qui varient et
ensuite le pib par personne qui varie
donc c'est pas on consomme moins de
pétrole parce que c'est la crise c'est
d'abord il ya moins de pétrole et
ensuite c'est la crise
et en fait d'abord il ya moins de
pétrole pour des raisons physiques vous
allez voir après que ce n'est pas le
prix qui fait l'extraction et une fois
que vous avez moins de pétrole vous avez
notamment - de transport donc un système
qui se freine un peu et à ce moment vous
avez moins de pib le choc pétrolier est
une conséquence du fait que comme le
pétrole est vendu sur un marché
instantanément son prix augmente mais ça
n'est pas la diffusion du choc pétrolier
dans l'économie qui fait baisser le pib
mondial puisque je vous ai montré tout à
l'heure qui avait pas bien entre le prix
du pétrole il pib mondial ça change
instantanément la location des rentes
donc ça fait la fortune de l'arabie
saoudite et ça fait le malheur de
l'europe ça c'est vrai mais mondialement
ça change pas grand chose le prix c'est
le volume qui change voyez variations
sur le volume variations sur le pib et
en ce qui concerne la production
mondiale de pétrole eh bien on y
reviendra au moment des questions
voilà où on en est voilà une projection
sur la production mondiale de pétrole
sur deux siècles voies larges et nous
sommes là
donc on est à quelques années près 5 ans
gi vortex la main on est à cinq ans la
question que tout le monde se pose est
celle du prix mais je vous ai dit à mon
avis c'est pas la question alors un
petit zoom sur l'europe pour finir vous
avez ici le pétrole à disposition de
l'europe alors vous voyez le pétrole de
la mer du nord c'est en rose rappelez
vous qu entre 2000 et 2008 le prix du
pétrole a très fortement augmenté la
production de la mer du nord a très
fortement baissé donc l'idée que quand
le prix du pétrole augmente on n'en
trouve plus on en extrait plus etc
ça se discute vous voyez également que
l'europe a perdu 10% de son pétrole
depuis 2006 donc ça date d'avant le
grenelle de l'environnement le fait
qu'on consomme de moins en moins de
pétrole
et ça va continuer et ça va continuer et
ça va continuer j'insiste pour le gaz
voici un pronostic centrale fait par
total qui montrent que la production
mondiale de gaz pourrait plafonner vers
2025 nonobstant le développement des gaz
non conventionnels dans le monde
nonobstant le développement des gaz non
conventionnels dans le monde dont je
vous montre en passant à quoi ça
ressemble un champ un champ de gaz non
conventionnel voilà j'ai quelques doutes
quant au fait qu'on puisse mettre ça
dans les cévennes et dans le bassin
parisien
voilà comment évolue l'approvisionnement
gazier en europe il vous plait voilà
comment évolue l'approvisionnement
gazier en europe vous voyez qu'il a
cessé de croître quand la mer du nord
qui représentent 60% de notre gaz a
passé son pic et donc j'ai quelques
doutes quant au fait que indépendamment
de la question climatique on puisse
remplacer le moindre nucléaire par du
gaz en europe
je ne suis pas complètement sûr que ça
va marcher parce que je pense que le gaz
ne sera pas là
et enfin je vais terminer avec deux
éléments sur le avec un élément sur le
changement climatique qui est juste ça
vous avez ici ce qui permet les
émissions qui permettent aux français de
vivre comme il vit c'est donc le bilan
carbone du français là dedans les agents
productifs ont disparu d'accord il n'ya
pas des missions attribuées dans cette
histoire à renault à total ou à bouygues
les émissions sont en totalité attribué
à vous et à moi et elles sont incluses
ses émissions dans la fabrication des
produits et services que nous utilisons
alors quels sont les produits et
services qui utilisent les français ils
font construire de temps en temps et
cette construction sachant qu'un mètres
carrés de logements béton c'est à peu
près 500 kg équivalent co2 pour le faire
1 l'essentiel est dans l'acier le ciment
nécessaire à la fabrication du logement
il ya 500 kg équivalent co2 dans un
mètre carré la fois où vous faites
construire 100 m² claque vous prenez 40
tonnes de co2 évidemment après faut la
portière sur le reste de votre vie et
donc rapporter à un français et à une
année ça fait en gros quelques centaines
de kilos de co2 par français et par an
pour l'activité de construction des
logements pas des magasins pas des
bureaux par la rénovation de l'assemblée
nationale
ensuite il faut avoir un confort
thermique dans ces logements donc il
faut utiliser de l'énergie pour ça et ça
ça fait un peu moins de deux tonnes
équivalent co2 par personne et par an
l'essentiel est occupée par les usages
thermiques chauffage et marginalement
eau chaude ici vous avez les émissions
correspondant à la production électrique
import export inclus ce calcul inclut
les échanges aux frontières de la france
donc l'électricité au charbon qu'on
importe de l'allemagne de temps en temps
etc c'est dedans
vous voyez que l'essentiel est dans le
confort thermique et bien évidemment
l'essentiel la totalité de ce confort
terminant ballon l'essentiel de ce
confort thermique est liée au fioul et
au gaz utilisé dans les chaudières
domestiques c'est marginalement là aussi
la production électriques qui
l'alimentent après les gens mangent
alors là vous avez essentiellement des
gaz or co2 vous avez le méthane du
cheptel bovin le protoxyde d'azoté de
l'utilisation des engrais est ce que
vous voyez ici c'est que l'alimentation
c'est 2,5 tonnes équivalent co2 par
personne et par an c'est plus que le
chauffage des logements de plus là
dedans la viande représente 40 % et en
fait si je fais viande et l'état je suis
à 50%
dix autres avant le fait qu'on ait envie
de manger des animaux c'est la moitié
notre empreinte carbone il faut savoir
qu'en france
81 70 % de l'ice a eu en gros de la
surface agricole utile est dévolue à
l'alimentation des animaux tous les
pâturages et la moitié des surfaces
céréalières
donc le fait qu'on ait envie de manger
des animaux pèse lourd dans l'empreinte
carbone des français
ensuite vous avez ici
l'achat des biens manufacturés hors
alimentation donc là dedans vous allez
trouver vos petites cuillères vos
machines à café vos chaussettes vos
chemises vos chaussures les automobiles
quand vous en achetez les agendas et c
deja en fait tout tout les absolus mans
tous les produits manufacturés qu'on
peut acheter pour lunettes sont là
dedans ce que vous voyez ici c'est que
la fabrication par l'utilisation la
fabrication de l'engin que mon voisin
est en train de consulter ou de
l'ordinateur que je suis en train
d'utiliser
c'est un coup bas je suis d'accord e
j'y reviendrai
la fabrication de l'électronique
utilisés par les particuliers donc là
dedans il n'ya pas les ordinateurs des
entreprises donc les écrans de
télévision et les ordinateurs des
particuliers aujourd'hui c'est un tiers
de l'empreinte carbone des achats de
produits manufacturés
un tiers entre 1990 et 2010 l'empreinte
carbone des français a augmenté de plus
de 10%
l'électronique grand public en
représentent les deux tiers au bas mot
d'accord donc penser que les
technologies de l'information
dématérialise la société pour le moment
c'est totalement faux ça c'est des
usages qui ont sont venues se rajouter
en plus des bagnoles et du chauffage des
logements et qui ont rajouté des
émissions et qui n'ont pas supprimé
enfin ici vous avez l'énergie utilisée
pour déplacer des individus dans leur
sphère privée alors la sphère privée
inclut dans ce calcul le déplacement
domicile travail
donc c'est le déplacement domicile
travail plus vous dans votre sphère
privée vous allez voir votre mère aux
enfants partaient en vacances vous allez
faire les courses afin voilà c'est tout
ça
la partie ici c'est la voiture et ça
c'est l'avion ça c'est pareil entre 1990
et 2010 la part qui a augmenté là dessus
c'est essentiellement l'avion je vous
rappelle que l'avion est essentiellement
concentrée sur les deux premiers déciles
en tout cas en loisirs il est concentré
sur les deux premiers déciles de la
population en gros ce qui fait que
rajouter un nouvel aéroport est une
infrastructure pour riches en parlant
j'ai rien dit
donc vous voyez ici les déplacements de
personnes 2 tonnes équivalent co2 et
enfin vous voyez ben oui c'est la
réalité et vous voyez ici les services
publics et privés qui représentent aussi
de l'ordre de 2 tonnes équivalent co2
par personne et par an alors c'est quoi
ces services publics et privés
l'école faut construire les bâtiments et
les chauffer et très accessoirement
maintenant mais des ordinateurs de dans
l'hôpital faut le construire faut le
chauffer faut fabriquer le plateau
technique toute l'industrie
pharmaceutique et tous les medical
systems abcd leurs émissions vont se
retrouver là dedans 1
et c'est un peu l'armé parce que l'armée
cram pas mal de fioul et de kérosène
pour jouer la bataille navale et à la
bataille aérienne et enfin ici vous avez
les services privés la banque le
coiffeur les opérateurs de téléphone etc
ce que vous voyez donc c'est que les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
partant lusage de l'énergie fossile sont
logés dans tout ce que nous faisons
toute la journée partout
et donc la caractéristique du problème
du changement climatique ou de la
dépendance à l'énergie fossile c'est que
c'est un problème que vous ne pouvez pas
résoudre en contraignant une petite
fraction de la population au bénéfice
des autres donc c'est pas comme un
problème d'environnement classique on
peut emmerder les agriculteurs ou les
fabricants de piles au mercure où les
gens qui font des avions ou chez pâquis
encore où les chimistes pour le bénéfice
du plus grand nombre c'est un problème
qu'on ne pourra résoudre qu'en demandant
une part d'efforts à tout le monde
et là on va retomber sur la noblesse de
votre métier je ne connais pas
historiquement d'exemple dans lequel on
puisse demander un effort collectif sans
qu'il y ait un projet collectif
extrêmement sexy dit autrement on ne
sortira jamais de ce problème sans
vision
sans vision c'est le chaos qui réglera
la situation
évidemment c'est toute la question de
savoir comment on fait émerger une
vision en démocratie avec des pâtes
nantes deux ans mais en face à vous
connaissez ça parker voit la fin des
explications préliminaires qui ont été
un peu longue et j'en suis désolé
et puis maintenant j'imagine que face
aux questions et bien merci merci
beaucoup
est ce qu'on pourra c'est une question
disposer du de la présentation aucun
problème merci beaucoup beaucoup
donc je vais maintenant passer la parole
au représentant des groupes j'ai
commencé par le groupe src donc arnaud
leroy et ensuite
martial saddier pour le groupe ump
arnaud leroy
le président
ici
les quelques minutes qui mettait louer
les avait dédié à autre chose à savoir
le changement climatique on va vite vous
étiez climatologues on m'avait dit on
m'avait dit j'ai lu quelques chroniques
également dans les échos il me
semblerait que vous étiez intéressé
j'ai cru j'ai cru mais moi j'ai
peut-être une vision de l'esprit gérer
mais bon je vais et je vais continuer
sur mon pour juste
parlez donc sûr
j'ai pris connaissance de vos graphiques
très bien c'est intéressant je pense que
théorie qui mérite d'être étudiée
dois vous avouer que moi je voulais
parler climat donc j'étais aussi j'étais
aussi puis cap là mais comme vous êtes
un ingénieur en plus vous êtes aussi
porteur de solutions est là dans votre
présentation on cherche les solutions
un début d'explication de tentatives je
suis d'accord avec vous sur un point la
démocratie l'effort global nécessaire et
je pense que l'effort global nécessaire
ne s'arrête pas qu'aux français
s'adressent aussi à l'ensemble de la
planète et je pense que c'est un des
éléments
que
votre
présentation look complètement à leur
apport à la démocratie parce qu'il est
quand même une question vous parlais
tout à l'heure des précaires
énergétiques qui semblerait être une
illusion je pense pas que ce soit le cas
et on est book c'est globalement un peu
ce que vous avez dit donc moi je peux
vous dire simplement que je viens de
discuter avec avec moult député
d'angleterre d'allemagne d'estonie du
danemark est ce qu'on appelle les fuel
pour ce sont un problème majeur
aujourd'hui ils sont au coeur de la
campagne électorale en allemagne donc je
pense pas qu'on puisse dire que c'est
une fumisterie que le le poste
énergétique dans le budget global des
familles n'a jamais été aussi bas peut
être mais en tout cas ni a ressenti
c'est comme l'humidité et la température
et on peut pas en termes démocratique
nier cet aspect deuxième point
l'acceptabilité je vous rejoins sur un
point je pense qu'il y aura des efforts
et que nous devons en tant que politique
avoir une vision et surtout un plant
pédagogie pour expliquer ses efforts et
le pourquoi donc voila un petit peu où
nous en sommes moi je voudrais aussi
vous entends vous avez parlé d'or de la
république on était à l'assemblée on
n'est pas sous les offres publiques on
est dans une chambre du peuple et on
doit pouvoir faire vivre cette ambition
démocratique la
secrétaire général de la convention
cadre sur les changements climatiques en
afrique as
voudrait voir beaucoup plus
d'implication
des autorités locales et des parlements
nationaux dans la mise en place du plu
un poste 2015 parce que je pense que
c'est un élément important vous avez
pointé cette date dans votre
présentation moi je voudrais qu'on s'y
arrête de minutes la france a fait le
choix
de se rendre disponible comme on dit en
jargon diplomatique pour accueillir
cette coop 21 en 2015 il ya l'ambition
très forte de la part de notre
gouvernement laurent fabius a indiqué
que la diplomatie climatique était
dorénavant un des axes prioritaires de
notre action extérieure j'aurais voulu
vous entendre un peu sur comment
participer enrichir accompagner parce
que nous avons encore quasiment deux ans
devant nous quelles sont les pistes que
vous pouvez proposer notamment pour
faire émerger cette idée qui est
intéressante je reconnais qu'ils
percutante sur la le problème de la
disponibilité l'énergie et non pas
simplement le prix je vous trouve
extrêmement critique envers les énergies
renouvelables donc
ça c'est quelque chose qui me met un
petit peu chiffonné surtout
monsieur geste critique je confirme
assez silencieuse sur votre rapport au
nucléaire
on a l'impression que
le blâme le blâme le blâme et sur les
énergies renouvelables très peu prolixe
sur les niches l'efficacité énergétique
donc voila moi m'a donné quatre minutes
je vois que j'ai déjà dépassé et donc et
maintenant je suis ravi que mes
collègues du groupe src qui sont quand
même heureux de vous accueillir ce matin
puisse poser leurs questions à leur tour
merci
juste une réponse de
16 heures de cours en ligne accessible
qui veut
donc des questions vont être posées
monsieur jancovici y aura possibilité dé
répondre martial s'allier pour le groupe
ump merci monsieur le président monsieur
jean kourichi merci au nom du député ump
de votre présence j'aimerais vous dire
vous venez d'exposer vos travaux vous
l'avez fait vous le savez avec brio vous
maîtrisez parfaitement et vous venez de
nous exposer un un constat qui est
respectable on peut être pourront peut
être content je le dis à tous les
collègues de la commission mais vous
avez un raisonnement dont on ne peut pas
dire au moins que du début jusqu'à la
fin n'est pas une certaine logique même
si on trouve sur le fond on peut en
penser chacun ce que l'on souhaite nous
les députés ump devraient souligner un
point profond d'accord avec vous c'est
l'enjeu sociétal
et c'est d'ailleurs en cela que nous
avions mis en place le grenelle 1 et
grenelle de l'environnement pour
associer tout le monde parce que l'enjeu
est effectivement mérite qu'il y ait
consensus et qui est surtout absence de
démagogie et de populisme sur un sujet
aussi important pour relever les défis
qui n'ont été qui ont été présentés vous
avez rappelé on peut pas le nier que le
président sarkozy n'a pas vraiment été
remercié mais vous avez aussi souligner
l destin funeste qui attend monsieur
hollande qui a aussi menti sur un
certain nombre de choses alors sur la
réflexion sociétale
c'est la première question il ya un
autre grand pays démocratique moderne
qui utilise l'énergie fossile ou le
président sortant a été réélu monsieur
obama il ya eu un débat et notamment un
débat énergétique comment analysez-vous
le débat sociétal qui a eu lieu il ya
quelques semaines aux états unis
deuxième remarque par rapport à votre
raisonnement on parle alors ce n'est pas
un avis que je donne mais je soulève des
questions il s'écrie beaucoup de choses
sur des réserves nouvelle potentielle
fossiles vous avez rappelé 300 millions
pour faire du pétrole 100 millions je
crois pour le gaz d'année mais est ce
que notamment les réserves potentielles
dont on nous dit qu'elle existerai
peut-être gaz de schiste
suppression de la glace pôle nord
notamment est ce que cela peut changer
dans un temps court peut-être ou pas le
raisonnement enfin vous n'en avez pas
fait référence
mais à l'énergie nucléaire dont on a
bien compris qu'elle concerne
essentiellement
l'électricité vous l'avez rappelé mais
par rapport à votre raisonnement quid de
la décision qui a été prise d'abaisser
la part du nucléaire et notamment sur un
exemple précis la fermeture de
fessenheim vous pouvez vous nous donner
votre avis sur ce point je passe la
parole à yannick favennec pour le groupe
u10 merci monsieur le président monsieur
jancovic y jouerait également vous
remercier au nom du groupe u10 pour
cette présentation
décoiffante et je voudrais vous vous
interrogez sur la conférence de doha et
sur le leadership français cette
conférence n'a pas été un échec pour
l'union européenne mais elle a été le
théâtre mondial de la capacité des
grandes puissances à à s'entendre sur
des objectifs de réduction d'émissions
de gaz à effet de serre est essentielle
à la survie de l'humanité à moyen terme
dans ce concert d'inertie je crois que
la france n'a pas à rougir de son bilan
dans sa lutte contre les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre en témoigne
d'ailleurs une étude récente allemande
qui nous place parmi les meilleurs
élèves du monde alors que le reste du
monde de 2010 à 2011 connaissaient une
augmentation de 3 % des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre la france quant à elle
réduit de 2 6 % notamment grâce aux
efforts consentis dans le cadre du
grenelle de l'environnement alors ses
performances que nous devons encore
amplifié doivent nous amener à prendre
le leadership au sein de l'union
européenne dans la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique climatique mais
ou est
ouest leadership aujourd'hui où est
passée volontarisme de notre pays qui
nous conduisait il y a encore quelques
mois imposée le plan climat énergie et
nos partenaires européens dans le cadre
de la présidence française non seulement
la voix de la france a disparu mais nous
avons aussi cédé sur les avancées que
nous avions nous-mêmes porte et je pense
aux au fonds vert de la conférence de
copenhague qui devait aboutir à
mobiliser 100 milliards d'euros à
l'horizon 2020 je pense aussi aux aides
destinées aux pays qui seront les
premières victimes du réchauffement
climatique je pense à la taxe carbone
aux frontières de l'europe la taxe sur
les containers ou sur les carburants
d'avion alors ma question j'ai deux
questions la première j'aurais voulu
connaître votre sentiment sur la
conférence de doha est sur la position
française au condo saône mais qu'elle
doit être selon vous le rôle de la
france dans ce domaine au sein de
l'europe et plus largement dans le cadre
des prochains sommets internationaux et
j'ai une deuxième question qui elle
concerne la réduction de la part du
nucléaire dans le bouquet énergétique
français
les énergies renouvelables actuelle
permettront-elles de compenser la baisse
de la part du nucléaire à l'horizon 2025
cette réduction est elle compatible avec
nos objectifs de réduction des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre je vous remercie
merci denis baupin pour le groupe oui
merci aux présidents moi aussi je
remercie jean marc jancovici pour son
ont explosé le ton provocateur qui là
qu'il a eu et pour dire que sur les
grands fondamentaux de ce qu'il a dit
nous nous sommes d'accord nous sommes
d'accord sur le diagnostic qu'il a posés
sur le fait que la crise dans laquelle
nous sommes n'est pas une crise
conjoncturelle qui pourrait repartir
demain avec une croissance qui redémarre
ray par enchantement mais que l'on est
bien face à une crise structurelle avec
la question énergétique est bien au
coeur de cette question de la crise qui
est posée est donc de ce point de vue je
pense que ce qu'il dit doit être entendu
comme un élément qui doit nous permettre
aux uns et aux autres de reconfigurer
certains de nos raisonnements il ya
évidemment un sujet qui n'a pas abordé
sur lesquels nous n'avons pas le même la
même position c'est que j'ai pas entendu
parler ni de tchernobyl ni de fukushima
ni des impacts que ça pouvait avoir ils
compris dans le calcul économique
si on intègre la question de l'accident
nucléaire dans le calcul économique je
pense que ycompris pour cette énergie ça
doit être quelque chose qui permet de
réécrire les équations parce que je
partage le point de vue qui consiste à
dire il faut que nous prenions en compte
dans le calcul économique tout ces
éléments qu'il a indiqué donc donner un
prix au carbone
donner un prix à l'épuisement des
ressources pétrolières donner un prix à
l'accident nucléaire tout ça dont nous
permettre de donner de la rationalité
dans le calcul économique donc si nous
sommes d'accord sur les constats après
reste la question quand même qu'il a peu
évoqué et qui nous paraît aujourd'hui la
plus importante c'est qu'est ce que nous
faisons de ces constats et comment nous
apportons nous abordons la suite une
fois que on a dit qu'il fallait revoir
les équations économique il faut aussi
revoir les équations énergétique nous ne
pouvons pas continuer à penser la
consommation énergétique sur le même
rythme que celui qui a été celui des
années précédentes même avec une
population qui va croissante et quand
l'agencé internationale de l'énergie qui
est donc je rappelle l'organisme de l'
ocde qui travaillent sur ces questions
énergétiques nous dit que face à
l'ensemble de ces périls énergétique les
priorités aujourd'hui de vale à 77% dans
la ssi bruce aubry y était et dans
l'efficacité énergétique à 19% dans les
énergies renouvelables elle dit
clairement l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie où doivent aller nos efforts
prioritaires pour lutter contre le
dérèglement climatique et l'épuisement
des ressources possibles je veux en
parler d'ailleurs pour dire que puisque
on nous parle souvent des états unis
comme un exemple sur l'année 2012 on a
installé plus de puissance éolienne aux
états unis qui ont installé de puissance
du gaz donc ça dit que sur ces questions
d'énergies renouvelables il ya
aujourd'hui des pays qui sont largement
plus avancé que la france je me permets
de rappeler aussi d'ailleurs qu' il y à
aujourd'hui 1662 éoliennes offshore en
europe 0 en france donc nous avons un
retard conséquent en matière
d'efficacité il a évoqué
et besoin de repenser nos questions
d'alimentation oui c'est un secteur dans
lequel on doit y réfléchir sur la part
de l'alimentation carnée dans notre
alimentation si on veut repenser ces
questions la question de la mobilité
c'est quoi la voiture de demain est ce
qu elle doit être aussi aux
consommatrices et aussi polluant quelle
est aujourd'hui la question des
bâtiments des queues de la consommation
énergétique y compris l'énergie il
existait spécifiques tous ces appareils
électroménagers que vous avez cités je
me permet aussi de rappeler que en
allemagne le ménage allemand qui n'est
pourtant pas moins dotés en appareils
électroménagers clos ménages français
consomment 20 % d'électricité spécifique
de moins que le ménage français 1 et je
compte pas le chauffage électrique le
chauffage électrique c'est 20% encore en
plus dans la consommation du ménage
français en matière d'électricité donc
on voit à quel point nos marges de
progression importante par rapport à un
pays voisin et donc sur sur ces
questions puisque la question doit être
posée de la croissance comme dans ce
pays on pense souvent croissance égale
emploi j'ai pas fini quand même déjà sur
le
et donc il te reste douze secondes oui
mais d'accord avec lui m'a interrompu
tout le temps jean paul et donc non mais
nous devons investir dans les secteurs
qui sont les plus intensifs en emploi
c'est une des questions essentielles et
donc en matière énergétique notamment le
secteur de la rénovation thermique des
bâtiments le secteur des transports
collectifs le secteur des énergies
renouvelables sont des secteurs bien
plus intensif en emploi que les énergies
fossiles et fissiles donc voilà ce que
ce que je souhaitais dire donc le débat
sur la transition énergétique
aujourd'hui en france est
particulièrement utile il est utile d'un
point de vue environnemental il est
utile d'un point de vue économique et je
suis d'accord sur le fait que nous avons
besoin d'avoir une vision mais on peut
en débattre nous on pense que en effet
c'est un sujet sur lequel on peut porter
un discours positif sur la façon dont la
transition énergétique est une réponse
par rapport à la crise
merci olivier falorni pour le groupe de
rdp
oui merci monsieur le président et merci
monsieur de de cet exposé qui bouscule
et je crois que lorsqu'on ouvre un débat
il est toujours utile d'être un peu
bousculé même si on peut être en
désaccord
alors à la lecture d'un certain nombre
de vos articles j'ai noté que le modèle
que vous défendez privilégie en priorité
la décarbonisation si je me trompe
d'abord des bâtiments puis de
l'industrie lourde et enfin des
véhicules et je vous rejoins sur ce
point mais quid de l'objectif de
réduction de 50% de la part du nucléaire
dans la production électrique française
vous le savez la conférence
environnementale pour la transition
énergétique a fixé ce cap pour 2025
comme pour la part des énergies
renouvelables dans le mix énergétique
alors comment peut-on à la fois
promouvoir le véhicule électrique
la pompe à chaleur et réduire la part du
nucléaire sans favoriser l'exploration
de gaz ou la production de biocarburants
alors à la lueur de vos connaissances
pourriez vous nous éclairer sur la
sortie du tout pétrole d'abord pour les
véhicules et sans avoir une vision trop
déformé du marché automobile ou dans les
grandes villes le taux de motorisation
diminue c'est un constat indéniable dans
les petites et moyennes villes ainsi que
dans les zones rurales l'automobile est
aujourd'hui indispensable et le taux de
motorisation augmente alors est-ce que
les biocarburants de troisième
génération produit à partir de
microalgues riches en lipides et qui
peuvent accumuler entre 60 et 80 % de
leur poids en acides gras ce qui
pourrait laisser présager une production
annuelle d'une trentaine de tonnes
d'huile par état est-ce que c'est
biocarburants de troisième génération
peuvent elle est une réponse adaptée à
titre de comparaison le rendement du
colza et 30 fois inférieur et puis
l'industrie concernée aussi par la
sortie du tout pétrole alors que la
production mondiale de pétrole ne va
plus beaucoup varié d'ici à 2020 elle se
mettra à décroître ensuite
l'europe connaît une baisse de sa
production de pétrole alors que ce
dernier représente 40% de son
approvisionnement énergétique et 33 %
pour la france alors l'indépendance de
la france au pétrole ne peut-elle pas
s'envisager grâce à l'exploitation des
gaz de schiste comme l'a souligné le
rapport de l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie pour les états unis alors on
le sait le retour d'expérience américain
n'est pas bon pour l'environnement c'est
le moins qu'on puisse dire mais il
existe d'autres formes d'exploitation
pour pallier les risques de la
fracturation hydraulique
alors que pensez-vous des recherches qui
vise à remplacer l'eau utilisée par
d'autres liquides comme du gpl ou même
du gaz carbonique et puis n'existe-t-il
pas une exploitation écologique des
hydrocarbures l'extraction du gaz de
houille contrairement au gaz de schiste
peut s'extraire sans recourir à la
fracturation hydraulique et enfin je
voulais aborder le rapport énergie 2050
rendu au début de l'année 2012 par le
centre d'analysé stratégique
qui propose quatre scénarii incarnant
des visions contrastées et des
méthodologies diverses pour aborder la
question de la production nucléaire et
au travers de vos publications j'ai lu
que vous étiez attachés à cette énergie
alors lequel de ces scénarios
accélération du nucléaire prolongation
du parc actuel réduction progressive ou
sortie complète devrions-nous adoptées
pour répondre aux exigences de la
décarbonisation
ce scénario doit-il considérer le
développement de l' usage des pompes à
chaleur et des véhicules électriques qui
implique par ailleurs une évolution du
réseau de distribution d'électricité
intelligents je voudrais évoquer en
conclusion l'exemple du danemark qui
réfléchit déjà au développement de ces
technologies et qui fait figure de bon
élève alors pourriez nous nous dire si
cet exemple danois qui au delà de ces
réflexions a déjà inscrit tout d'abord
l'augmentation de la part des énergies
non renouvelables à 35 % de sa
production énergétique deuxièmement la
réduction de sa consommation brute
d'énergie de 12 % entre 2006 et 2020
troisièmement une production électrique
dominé par l'éolien à 50% pourriez-vous
donc nous dira si la politique danoise
est la voie à suivre pour réussir notre
transition énergétique je vous remercie
merci avant de passer la parole à
patrice carvalho pour le groupe gdr
il ya 17 intervenants donc vous préparer
pour une minute chacun
si vous voulez bien donc je vous ai
proposé prévenu patrice carvalho pour le
groupe gdr merci ce président a coûté
voilà la première la première réaction
c'est que c'est une intervention qui à
mon sens des coiffes un petit peu et pas
est pas habituel dans les propos bon
ceux qui me connaissent savent que je
pratique pas non plus la langue de bois
et dont je par habitude mais ce crime
est assez clairement parfois assez
durement mais là j'avoue que d'exposer
bon c'est un exposé quand tu es un peu
hard et même si je pars très sens un tas
de choses qui ont été dites
la première chose qui est qui qui me
pose problème d'ailleurs moi je connais
c'est max et son explication sur la
société capitaliste qui conduisait la
crise sans fin qu'aux connaît
aujourd'hui bon je connais maintenant
jancovici qui a amélioré un petit peu
cette réflexion qu'on a connu
par contre pas quoi qu'il ya des
contradictions qui ont été vite lorsque
vous avez exprimée par exemple vous
dites attention l'explosion si des gens
peuvent s'alimenter normalement si les
gens peuvent faire voir une explosion ce
que vous ne prévoyez c'est d'explosion
la fin inévitablement puisqu'en fait
s'il ya plus de croissance en europe y'a
plus satisfaction des besoins et les
besoins aujourd'hui sont loin d'être
satisfaits y compris en france on met
deux millions de personnes dans les rues
aujourd'hui pour pour un doigt sur le
mariage
et et et hey hey hey hey hey en
maintenant et en même temps voilà on ne
retrouvera pas les débats me sens on a
six millions de personnes
il ya 6 il ya six millions de personnes
qui vivent du chômage ou qui sont au
chômage on a des gens qui arrivent
presque loger des gens car il faut se
nourrir enfin des gens qui arrivent car
il faut soigner bon ça c'est des choses
qui sont quand même concrètes alors moi
quand je vois la prospective je vous dis
que tout ça c'est un petit peu pour
l'avenir compliqué et puis comment
comment réduire comment réduire je
dirais notre façon de vivre à maquereau
veulent nous ramener un petit peu al
alagi en afrique avec nos dames qui vont
taper
dans les gamelles pour faire à manger
pendant les hommes y sont la chasse les
zones seront la chasse
donc et et ea et un retour en arrière
que votre jeu n'évolue pas du tout bon
on va parler de nos grands-mères qui
faisait la lessive dans les rues et
c'est bon reckitt rivières on peut
revenir à tout ça d'accord mais ça me
paraît un peu compliqué il ya il ya
quelque chose que je partage
fondamentalement c'est là la question
qui concerne les médias le rôle de
médium en fait c'est la pensée unique
pour convoyer pas nos sociétés possible
tout est foutu regardez ce qui s'est
passé à l'aise dans le passé et c'est
tout ça c'est foutu remet tout la trappe
d'amnesia préfet sont autres d'ailleurs
même lcp même lcp qu'une télévision qui
est dans le système le plus complet elle
qui est appelé en principe à faire
réfléchir et à face exprimée les députés
eh bien écoutez je suis désolé à baradel
à tous les jours les uns et les autres
pas seulement qu'on vous y passer mais
regardez là vous verrez que ça apporte
rien plus que tf1 antenne 2 et fr3 que
c'était donc le saas est un problème
choses au nom
d'un grand balayage alors moi moi je
voudrais je voudrais quand même je
voudrais quand même marché que je fais
comme vous je fais quand vous j'en
profite donc aux nouvelles données
devraient quand même parlé aussi un
petit peu de des possibilités de
modifier les ressources énergétiques on
est à l'âge de pierre encore demain avec
toi faire l'énergie simplement avec
cette bouteille d'eau pour des semaines
c'est pas bon c'est pas fou et grecs le
scientifique soit capable un jour de
faire autre chose
et puis ce que ce que je regrette quand
même c'est que votre votre message est
fort mais
c'est quoi les perspectives qu'est ce
que vous nous proposez c'est vrai tu es
beaucoup c'est la deuxième partie est
beaucoup plus intéressant voilà et puis
j'ai eu peur parce que quand j'ai vu
beaucoup de collègues partis j'ai cru
qu'à un moment donné vous nous proposez
suicide collectif
après un message aussi dur voilà si
un certain humour
merci alors donc une minute philippe
plisson
sur le président une minute ça va être
dur
on ne peut partager votre diagnos le
mans n'ont simplement une juste que je
voulais ce que je voulais vous dire je
j'interromps philippe une minute pas
pour l'embêter simplement
jancovici après répondre à moi
j'aimerais bien qu'il ne réponde pas
devant une salle vide le problème on le
vit régulièrement donc j'aimerais bien
qu'il ne réponde pas dans une salle vide
donc respecter les temps de parole que
que je vous donne je veux dire les
analyses elles sont elles sont faites
elles ont souvent été fait simplement
c'est peut-être une question à laquelle
pour l'acompte douala philippe
donc on ne peut que partager votre
diagnostic qui est malheureusement
connue ce qui nous intéresse ça a été
dit ce sont les solutions vous partez du
postulat qu'il n'y aura plus de
croissance au lieu au lieu de rester
dans le modèle de développement des
années soixante dix ne pensez vous pas
que c'est un inconvénient pourrait
devenir une chance en changeant
radicalement de modèle ce qui remettrait
par exemple les énergies renouvelables
que vous méprisez au coeur du dispositif
deuxième question dans ce contexte
pouvez vous me donnez votre position par
rapport à l'exploitation des gaz de
schiste et que pensez-vous des clac rade
de méthane épée de damoclès climatique
ou ressources énergétiques potentiel
merci jean marie sermier
mais c'est bien oui monsieur le
président c'est d'ailleurs une question
que je partage avec mon collègue yves
albarello
vous avez parlé d'un
constat qui effectivement partagé par le
plus grand nombre ce que je souhaiterais
que vous puissiez abordé c'est
maintenant la gouvernance d'une fin
d'une réflexion sur l'énergie on voit
bien qu'on peut pas aujourd'hui dans ce
pays prendre des mesures alors qu'en
même temps en chine nous avons une
centrale à charbon qui s'ouvre chaque
semaine quelle gouvernance faut-il pour
que au niveau mondial on puisse avoir
des avancées significatives
vous avez parlé d'un projet sexy et pour
l'avenir
le sexy c'est forcément là où chacun
peut s'y retrouver est ce que on a
aujourd'hui le temps nécessaire de bâtir
un projet de le faire valider par le
plus grand nombre y compris par les
autres pays pour faire en sorte que nous
puissions intéresser la population dans
la réflexion que vous avez proposé et
puis dernier point vous avez à peine
abordée l'hydrogène en disant que ça
coûtait cher énergiquement libre
l'hydrogène fatale selon vous at elle
quand même un avantage
merci geneviève gaillard oui merci
monsieur le président je voudrais dire
merci à monsieur jancovici et lui dire
que effectivement je partage avec lui
les grands fondamentaux qu'il nous a
présenté je suis resté sur ma faim parce
qu'évidemment vous ne présentez pas
monsieur des solutions ou du moins des
perspectives de solutions
pour les années à venir alors j'aurai
vous de poser deux questions la première
c'est que on sait que l'énergie la plus
propre c'est celle que l'on ne consomme
pas est ce que la france aujourd'hui est
armée pour pouvoir rentrer dans la
transition énergétique et avancer dans
ce domaine la deuxième question j'en ai
trois en fait un deuxième question en
termes de fiscalité écologique est ce
que vous avez des choses à nous proposer
parce que là aussi nous avons une
réflexion importante et on sait qu'il ya
des choses à faire et troisièmement
quelle quelle est votre réflexion sur
l'aménagement du territoire vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui on a de grandes
réflexions aussi sur l'aménagement du
territoire les métropoles l'étaient les
territoires qui se désertifient comment
est ce que vous voyez demain avec les
problématiques qui se posent et bien
notre territoire français merci merci
monsieur edouard philippe merci merci
d'abord pour la présentation qui était
évidemment provocatrice mais aussi
perturbantes et stimulante du point de
vue intellectuel je voudrais poser de
questions et faire une remarque la
première question c'est vous nous avez
indiqué qu'il était temps prendre en
compte les indicateurs et notamment les
instigateurs de prélèvement sur les
stock et j'aurais aimé savoir si en
france ou à l'étranger il y avait des
recherches
dans le monde économique où dans le
monde de la comptabilité nationale pour
mieux prendre en compte ce prêt 7 ces
éléments de près les agressions de
prélèvement sur les stock de
éventuellement nous deux nous dire un
petit mot sur la taxe carbone sur un
bref tous tous ces indicateurs qui sont
comptables qui sont même économique et
qui permettrait de mieux traduire la
réalité des coûts tels que vous l'avez
décrite ma deuxième question
vous avez finalement dit peu de choses
sur les impacts de tout ce système sur
le climat et vous avez montré qu'il y
avait une diminution de la ressource
énergétique qu'il fallait prendre en
compte mais vous n'avez pas mis
d'échelle de temps sur l'impact lié aux
émissions de gaz à effet de serre qui
était lié à cette ressource énergétique
et la troisième chose et non pas évident
je vais très vite c'est dire quand même
que c'est un message que moi je
considère comme un message intéressant
et d'espoir parce qu'au fond pour nous
parlementaires pour nous élus politiques
vous dites qu'en réalité ne ça n'est pas
condamné mais que c'est à nous
d'inventer les réponses qui doivent
prendre en compte la réalité que vous
décrivez est donc finalement je le
prends comme un message de prise de
pouvoir des élus est pas un message de
condamnation des élus merci à nos
responsabilités jacques krabal qui ne
pourra pas parler de jean de la fontaine
à mon rêve
j'en suis vraiment navré donc pour aller
pour aller rapide pour aller vite je
rêve revenir sur les énergies des
hydrocarbures non conventionnels
vous n'en a parlé n'en avais pas
beaucoup parlé seulement à travers un
slide on vous dit une remarque sur les
des gaz et huiles de schiste en faisant
penser que vous êtes opposé défavorable
je voudrais savoir pour quelle raison
après vous semblez fr apparaître
certaines est vraiment à l'égard des
énergies renouvelables simplement à
travers le fait qu'elle représente peu
est ce qu'il y à d'autres arguments
concernant le nucléaire vous n'en avez
pas du tout peur vous citez même dans
votre livre j'aimerais bien avoir
quelques commentaires parce que vous
êtes assez assez sûr de vous est ce que
vous revenez sur cette expression en
disant que concernant la catastrophe de
tchernobyl
à ce jour aucune aucune épidémiologie
n'a pu mettre en évidence un quelconque
surcoût de mortalité pour par concert ou
à cet accident
il a parlé quelques dizaines de décès
que cela représente alors qu'on sait
bien dans d'autres études que ça peut
aller de 5000 à 80 mille morts donc vous
êtes assez agrégé en certitude dans
votre expression j'aimerais savoir si
vous le maintenez vous le maintenez par
rapport à cette assertion qui apparaît
cependant aujourd'hui merci sylviane
alaux
oui
mes questions vont peut-être paraître un
peu décalé par rapport à la nature de
votre exposé mais je vous ai lu
concernant le gaz de schiste ce que vous
appelez la fausse bonne idée je profite
donc de votre présence parmi nous
aujourd'hui pour vous poser quelques
questions la première sur quelles études
vous basez vous pour affirmer cela finn
parce que finalement la réalité est que
l'on bloque sur la méthode d'extraction
qui est il est vrai particulièrement
dommageable pour notre planète mais
deuxième question ne doit-on pas
encourager la recherche pour trouver
d'autres méthodes de destruction
d'ailleurs certains pays commencent à
s'y atteler doit-on rester les bras
croisés à attendre pendant que cherche
j'aurais aimé revoir votre sentiment sur
ces deux questions sur ces deux sujets
joue remercier jacques kossowski merci
président un monsieur dans le cadre de
la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique
je vous ai très partisan du recours à
l'énergie nucléaire civile qui d'après
vous serez beaucoup moins dangereuse que
par exemple le charbon vous pensez que
l'élévation des températures sur notre
planète aura un impact beaucoup plus
grave que l'écosystème de ces
catastrophes disons dans les centrales
c'est ce qui vient d'être dit tout à
l'heure je faisais lui aussi et même si
cela doit faire réagir certains de
collègues et c'est le cas je
souhaiterais que vous puissiez nous
expliciter votre position en faveur du
nucléaire dont l'utilisation un terme
apparaît comme très contestée par le
gouvernement actuel merci merci merci
madame brigitte allain
oui merci monsieur le président je vais
concentrer mama questions sur
l'alimentation
dans votre exposé nous avons vu tout à
l'heure que l'alimentation un fort
impact
concernant notre
nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre
vous savez je suppose que scénarii ont
été étudiées concernant l'évolution de
notre de nos besoins alimentaires d'ici
2050 parce que c'est bien de cela qu'il
faut partir si on ne veut pas diminuer
notre alimentation en tous les cas ça
suppose de réels changements mais les
scénarii prévoit effectivement de une
alimentation qui évolue mais aussi des
besoins énergétiques et donc ça suppose
de changer confondant mentalement de
politique agricole
que pensez-vous de scénarii qui ont été
proposés par afs terre par exemple et
qui implique notamment des régions pour
évoluer vers vers d'autres pratiques et
qui
disent clairement qu'il faut un
rendement croissant date d'adoption
c'est à dire que s'il n'y a pas une
adoption
quasi générale des politiques de ceux
qui pratiquent l'agriculture
du tout l'entourage il ne peut pas y
avoir d'évolution
donc ce sont ces scénarii là qu'il faut
mettre en oeuvre et donc avoir une
réelle politique merci serge bardy merci
au président mais c'est comme si je
faisais comme vous l'avez dit chacun
d'entre nous est bien entendu d'accord
en tant que législateur elle peut et
doit s'intéresser à la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
établir un cadre juridique alors il ya
quand même au niveau mondial comment
pourriez vous nous indiquez à votre avis
quels sont les points de blocage qui
depuis vingt ans après le sommet de la
terre de rio rendent aussi ardu et
inopérante la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique au niveau
international et notamment au regard des
institutions en charge de cette lutte
dans divers documents que vous avez
publié vous esquissez quelques pistes
sur le programme d'action qui à vos yeux
serait souhaitable en la matière alors
deux questions majid noter une
proposition résidant sur la nomination
d'un conseiller technique dans chaque
cabinet de chaque ministère et dans
chaque direction générale européenne ou
envoyer dans une cour des comptes
rebaptisé cours du développement durable
pour le goût et vous nous préciser cette
proposition quel serait le rôle précis
de ses conseillers par ailleurs vous
dites aussi vous évoquez la baisse
nécessaire la demande en matériel
d'électricité de chaleur et de mobilité
en période de crise comment concilier
une forte augmentation des tarifs
énergétiques sans diminuer brutalement
le niveau de vie des français dont une
grande partie est dors et déjà
fragilisés
l'augmentation des tarifs de l'énergie
pour eux auraient des conséquences
catastrophiques pourriez vous nous
confirmez votre réflexion en la matière
et je voudrais terminer par une petite
provocation et constructif aussi quelles
propositions pourriez vous nous faire
pour concilier engagement
quarante-et-une du président hollande à
savoir une baisse de la part du
nucléaire de 75 à 50% avec une baisse de
nos émissions de co2
merci essayé de respecter s'il vous
plaît jean pierre vigier
merci monsieur le président monsieur
jancovici merci pour votre brillant
exposé que j'ai bien apprécié qui
décoiffe et qui change des exposés
classique que l'on a le gouvernement
aujourd'hui veut réduire la part du
nucléaire mais il faudra bien remplacer
cette part d'énergie et vous l'avez vous
l'avais déjà dit ce n'est pas l'éolien
et le photovoltaïque qui vont remplacer
en totalité cette manque d'énergie nous
avons le gaz le charbon le pétrole mais
plusieurs problèmes
on sera dépendant des autres pays ont
pour leur a en plus rap pardon beaucoup
plus par l'émission de co2 et d'après
votre exposé les re si j'ai bien compris
les ressources en charbon diminue
fortement alors deux questions que
fait-on et quelle est votre position sur
le sujet
merci merci charles ange ginésy
oui monsieur jean koichi merci pour cet
exposé qui effectivement apporter un
éclairage nouveau et pour ma part je
voudrais vous poser une question qui
consiste à dire et je suis d'accord avec
vous qu'il faut dans la transition
énergétique moins consommer d'énergies
fossiles mais en même temps vous nous
expliquer que les énergies renouvelables
ne représentent rien sur le par sur
l'appareil verger tic donc ne peut-on
pas trouvé dans cette diminution de
notre consommation un équilibre qui
fasse qu'on ne se trouve pas en
décroissance parce que ce qui m'a le
plus marqué
c'est quand vous dites je préconise le
budget à croissance zéro je préconise un
budget qui n'avance plus or on sait qu
économiquement parlant s'il n'y a pas de
croissance notre société ne trouvera pas
une capacité à rebondir et puis ce qui
m'a interpellé également c'est le fait
que vous disiez que sur la recherche il
n'y a pas de possibilité d'obtenir un
avenir je crois moi pour ma part que la
recherche doit représenter demain une
nouvelle espérance merci christophe
priou
oui alors que là on avait parlé en notre
temps du plombier polonais quel avenir
vous pouvez décrire pour le marin
pêcheur breton puisque va-t-il pouvoir
continuer à les en mer la ressource on
s'aperçoit aussi que s'il faut manger -
carnets le poisson est de plus en plus
poissons d'élevage donc aussi nrj puis
le marin pêcheur qui se loge et on a
bien vu sur certaines cartes que la
pression c'était la population a été
vers les pôles urbains et vers le
littoral et que souvent la maison du
pêcheur est devenue une résidence
secondaire et qu'on construit maintenant
pour les jeunes pêcheurs sur les terres
agricoles donc quel urbanisme pour pour
demain quand on voit également la part
de consommation de la construction de
logements et de l'énergie pour habiter
celui ci jean louis bricout et ensuite
monsieur une riche
oui monsieur
jancovici monsieur le président excusez
moi de mon retard j'ai pas pu apprécier
votre intervention je crois j'ai dû
louper quelque chose
mais j'aime et je crois que dans vos
travaux vous appeler nos villes à se
moderniser notamment du point de vue de
l'urbanisme et de l'aménagement du
territoire de même vous plaidez pour que
les collectivités à s'acquitter d'une
taxe carbone je crois donc pour autant
vous n'êtes pas sans ignorer la la que
la complexité le contexte financier
difficile dans lequel les collectivités
honte à boucler leur budget c'est
pourquoi ma question sera simple comment
envisagez vous la mise en place de cette
taxe due et d'une façon plus générale
dans votre théorie quel rôle assigné
vous à l'état dans sa mission
d'accompagnement des collectivités
territoriales merci michel heinrich et
madame sophie of reach ensuite
si le président je vais être très bref
vous avez conclu monsieur jancovici
merci encore pour votre travail exposé
qui nous a je crois c'est ce qui nous a
réveillés ensuite peut-être un peu
abasourdi vous disiez vous en conclusion
on ne sortira pas du problème sans
vision où c'est le chaos qui règlera le
problème à votre avis chaos ou capacité
d'avoir une vision et
concernant la taxe carbone la cat da
taxe carbone appliquée un pays peut elle
être un gadget temporairement utile
merci madame s'offrir fritsch oui merci
monsieur le président je dois avouer que
cet exposé effectivement été passionnant
j'ai certainement la plupart d'entre
nous pas tout compris mais peut-être
compris quand même qu'avec ce nouveau
modèle que vous nous proposez le débat
c'est plus sur la transition énergétique
c'est sur la transition tout court et
qu'on a une formidable occasion ou
plutôt une opportunité vu que le coût du
capital n'a jamais été si peu cher
d'investir massivement
enfin pour développer le cas échéant des
énergies renouvelables ou alors investir
massivement peut-être pour développer le
nucléaire dont finalement le rendement
et et maximum en tout cas en matière de
production électrique donc question sur
le nucléaire comme beaucoup d'autres de
mes de mes collègues ensuite quel est le
bon échelon de réflexion pour un élu est
ce que c'est vraiment le petit
territoire la france l'europe évidemment
l'idéal ce serait le monde mais on peut
pas réfléchir tous ensemble et adopter
les mêmes positions enfin dans un de vos
articles vous suggériez puisque les
prévisions de l'aïe eux sont jamais
conforme finalement à ce qu'elles
prétendent être la création d'une
commission parlementaire sur sur les
travaux de l'aij eux et sur la meilleure
façon de prévoir les quantités d'énergie
notamment fossiles
peut-être que le président pourrait
aussi lui suggérer la création de cette
commission pour que nous saisissions du
cij ils veulent barrer l'eau et merci
monsieur le président monsieur jancovic
une question volontairement provocatrice
je vous écoute voilà je vous écoute et
vous m'écoutez je vous pose une question
voilà je disais une question
volontairement provocatrice
est ce que nous nous persistons pas dans
l'erreur à vouloir améliorer sans arrêt
notre bilan carbone lorsque le plus gros
consommateur d'énergie fossile au monde
la chine ouvre et j'ai été effaré par le
chief où l'avait cité tout à leur ouvre
une centrale à charbon
par semaine et donc forcément le bilan
carbone il est négatif en chine plus
positif chez nous et donc ça s'annule
est-ce qu'on persiste pas dans l'erreur
ou la règle du jeu doit être content si
ce n'est que la chine est le pays qui
investit le plus dans les énergies
renouvelables
il faut aussi le signaler
mais oui oui oui mais bon jeu je
voudrais simplement dire je vais
simplement dire que le temps de parole
dont je dispose est très peu utilisé
jusqu'à jusqu'à maintenant vous aurez pu
le constater je suis quand même d'une
très grande réserve et en général j'ai
vite j'évite de piéger les
parlementaires qui sont là beaucoup de
poser des questions pour écouter
pourrait changer bien entendu avec les
personnes qui est invité mais c'est vrai
que je suis
particulièrement vigilants et
respectueux des responsabilités des
parlementaires de 7
de cette commission voilà ce que je
souhaitais dire je
voilà merci beaucoup vous êtes gentil
david david douillet et vous ruine
minutes merci
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues
dans une tribune qui est paru le 6
janvier dans le jdd
vous expliquer donc vous l'avez dit cela
mais je vous le dit aussi de manière que
sans une sans énergie je vous cite à
profusion il n'y aurait ignoré
aujourd'hui ni pouvoir d'achat multiples
x 50 en 150 ans ni baisse du temps de
travail à 35 heures ni aliments à
profusion en toute saison ni mobilité
pour tous ni espérance de vie passée de
25 à 80 ans de siècle etc alors si
l'énergie et comme vous le le développer
dans cette tribune et comme je vous
l'avais développeurs et la base de
l'ensemble de l'économie
comment vous envisagé
si mes collègues me laisse parler la
transition énergétique qui serait alors
une transition beaucoup plus globale
dans notre modèle économique actuel est
pas un simple glissement d'une énergie à
une autre et puis est-ce que vous pensez
que en france nous sommes en retard ou
pas est-ce qu'on a anticipé les choses
merci merci de d12 derniers intervenants
alain gest et ensuite jacques alain
bénisti merci
messieurs présence de jean claude dusse
a fait la troisième fois je vous écoute
à chaque fois c'est un vrai bonheur
parce que c'est un discours qu'on a
qu'on n'entend pas souvent
tout à fait
président vous soutiens vous quand même
pas exagérer
je voulais simplement vous demandez je
vous ai déjà entendu dire et pas
aujourd'hui que à la solution au
problème des carburants automobiles
compte tenu de ce qui va arriver sur le
plan du pétrole et que vous êtes sur une
ligne proche de cocher dans ce domaine
c'est qu'il fallait multiplier par deux
voire par trois le prix des carburants
on vous avait dit à l'époque d'ailleurs
dans la mission réchauffement climatique
qu'on vous confierez volontiers le poste
de ministre qui va bien pour l'expliquer
aux citoyens et et puis je vous ai vu
dans un article que la commission nous a
intelligemment adressé d'ailleurs parlé
de des tarifs subventionnés sur le gaz
et l'électricité et dire que c'était pas
comme ça qu'il fallait s'y prendre
j'aimerais un petit peu connaître votre
avis sur la vérité des prix en matière
d'énergie
merci pour conclure chacun à bénisti oui
merci monsieur président la question que
je voulais poser à monsieur jean koffi
fils était
que ce matin vous savez un énième séisme
d'amplitude 8 donc a eu lieu dans le
pacifique face aux îles fidji et pas
très loin d'ailleurs de la nouvelle
calédonie qui est actuellement donc on
en a mais on alerte maximum je veux
savoir pensez vous qu'il y a un rapport
de cause à effet entre le changement
climatique et les mouvements géologiques
koné connaissons de plus en plus ces
derniers mois merci bien écoutez
monsieur jean cau russie vous avez la
parole
beaucoup de sujets migrants
alors ça va peut-être un peu décousu je
vais commencer par deux ou trois
remarques générales la première c'est
comme vous vous en doutez bien je vais
pas pouvoir répondre de manière
détaillée à toutes les questions de
détails
un
certain nombre qui ont été pour candy de
détail c'est une technique particulière
en etc
pour ceux qui ont le temps je sais que
c'est une denrée précieuse pour vous
encore plus que pour moi il ya des
réponses sur mon site personnel
de temps en temps je vous dirais confère
ce que j'ai écrit sur le sujet parce que
malheureusement j'aurais pas le temps de
traiter ce matin et je pense plus utile
de vous livrer des choses un peu plus
générale la deuxième chose c'est qu'il
ya une remarque que je fais très souvent
avoir une intervention c'est d'expliquer
que les malentendus vont toujours se
nicher dans ce qui n'a pas été dit
et en 45 minutes ou en 50 minutes ont
fait 45 ou 50 minutes un certain nombre
d'entre vous ont fait la remarque à
laquelle je souscris évidemment qu'on ne
parle pas de transition énergétique on
parle de transition tout court et on
parle de projet de société à long terme
donc en gros il s'agit d'aller conquérir
la lune quoi c'est pas une affaire de
transition énergétique
à partir du moment où on accepte l'idée
qu'on va toucher à tout dans cette
affaire explique est la solution à tout
en 45 minutes vous fassiez quelqu'un a
la solution dans cette salle je prends
ça m'intéresse beaucoup je le recycleur
s étire constance dans plein d'autres
occasions
le la deuxième chose que je veux dire
c'est que je vais pour impressionner mes
filles ce soir leur disant que j'ai
parlé un champion olympique ça c'est
quand même quelque chose
alors
non non non non
vous savez il faut aller chercher les
gens là où ils seront donc des
adolescentes de ces ombres
en fait je vais en faire une remarque
beaucoup général faut aller chercher les
gens là où ils sont 1 l'idée que les
gens vont aller tout seul à là où il
faudrait qu'ils aillent malheureusement
ça marche pas donc faut vraiment aller
chercher les gens là où ils sont
quelques questions ont été posées sur la
question sur les ressources et notamment
sur les gaz de schiste sans ça je vais
quand même y répondre ordre de grandeur
l'europe consomme aujourd'hui 500
milliards de mètres cubes de gaz par an
là dedans 300 viennent de la mer du nord
le détail du calcul et sur mon site dont
je vous donne juste le résultat ce qu'on
pourrait obtenir des gaz non
conventionnel est de l'ordre de quelques
dizaines de milliards de mètres cubes
par an en europe voilà c'est ça leur de
grandeur sur une consommation annuelle
qui fait aujourd'hui 500 je vais vous
donner maintenant un cas plus
particulier qu'est celui de la france la
france et 50 milliards de mètres cubes
par an la diana 30 dans le chauffage 15
dans l'industrie si le seul problème
c'est
de satisfaire les demandes des chimistes
français avec en conservant en 15 de
consommation de gaz naturel en france on
s'en sort sans problème et la question
est de supprimer les 30 qu'on a dans le
chauffage qui soit dit en passant d'un
coût de 6 milliards d'euros
d'importations parents et ça ça se fait
que de l'isolation et des pompes à
chaleur on n'a pas besoin de gaz pour ça
donc sortir le gaz et le fioul des
usages thermiques dans le bâtiment est
une des premières priorités à mon sens
dans tout conquête de la lune puisque
moi c'est comme ça que j'ai envie c'est
le nom que j'ai envie de lui donner et
j'ai d'autant plus envie de lui donner
ce nom là que comme je les dis un
certain nombre de fois il va falloir
demander de l'effort à tout le monde et
l'effort partagé par tous n'est possible
que quand il ya un truc un peu excitant
en face donc quand vous dites à un
astronaute qui va aller sur la lune il
est d'accord pour se mettre pendant une
semaine dans une boîte de conserve
risquer sa vie pas voir sa femme etc et
tout ça parce qu'en face il a un truc il
excite beaucoup je pense que si on a pas
et ça c'est votre métier je suis désolé
ce n'est pas le mien si on n'a pas une
vision exaltante à long terme a proposé
aux pays c'est pas la peine de songer à
la bonne manière de lui demander des
efforts on peut bricoler poser des
rustines etc mais c'est c'est pareil et
c'est exactement le même sujet soit dit
en passant pour l'argent et je vais
prendre un exemple tiré de la vie
courante si un de vos enfants vient vous
voir en vous disant oh papa ou maman où
je lui ai déconné non excusez-moi
parents dans le futur quotidien parle
donc papa ou maman j'ai déconné et j'ai
500 euros de trop sur mon compte en
banque il faudrait bouche et vous allez
traîner les pieds le faire une fois
parce que vous l'aimez bien puis la
deuxième vous allez commencer à trouver
que la plaisanterie a assez duré le même
bien vous voir une semaine après en
disant papa ou maman j'ai un projet pour
l'avenir et j'ai besoin de 10000 euros
vous les avez vous payez vous avez passé
un autre sujet vous avez vous payé donc
là on est exactement dans la même
configuration on n'arrête pas de se
demander où on va trouver l'argent pour
faire des trucs dans un an avec une
mentalité de bouchage avait deux pauses
de rustines
on va bricoler et on trouvera pas la
moitié des machins dont on a besoin si
on est dans une optique de conquête de
la lune l'argent ce n'est pas le sujet
l'argent c'est pas le sujet on trouve on
a trouvé mille milliards pour sauver les
banques c'est pas le sujet c'est
vraiment pas le sujet
ce qui est le sujet c'est l'arbitrage
car on n'aura pas de l'argent pour tout
et ça j'y reviens on n'aura pas à la
fois de l'argent pour donner un travail
à tout le monde donnait de l'espoir à
tout le monde et donné plus de
consommation à tout le monde ça on aura
plus mais préserver la stabilité socio
économique du pays avec de l'espoir et
un travail pour tous ça en trop c'est
vraiment pas le sujet la deuxième
remarque un peu général que je voudrais
faire et se rapproche à ça c'est quid de
la france dans les négociations
internationales climat alors je voulais
dit l'énergie fossile c'est pouvoir
d'achat et c'est le niveau de vie jamais
en fait quand vous comprenez les choses
comme ça jamais vous ne peuvent parvenir
à la conclusion que des hauts
fonctionnaires aussi méritants soit ils
peuvent se réunir quelque part dans le
monde et décidé de leur côté de niveau
rationnel de consommation des individus
dans le monde ça peut pas marcher ça ne
peut pas marcher ce qui peut marcher
c'est que une région du monde parce
qu'elle est le dos au mur se lance dans
cette affaire de manière extrêmement
résolue structuré et massive alors la
raison pour laquelle j'ai attiré votre
attention ce matin sur la particularité
de la situation énergétique de l'europe
en matière de carburant et de gaz c'est
parce que je vous dis l'europe est le
dos au mur elle y est donc notre choix
sans regret c'est de nous lancer de
manière résolue dans une économie qui
utilisent de moins en moins de
combustibles fossiles ça doit être ça
notre conquête de la lune et ça doit
nous occuper 40 ans et c'est pas une
transition à 100 milliards c'est une
transition à 5000 enfin calcul d'ordre
de grandeur l'ordre de grandeur des
investissements qu'il faut consentir
pour refaire les villes refaire les
infrastructures de transport refaire le
paysage agricole parce que le paysage
agricole qu'on a fait aujourd'hui ne
convient pas un monde sous stress
énergétique
un camion sur trois transporte quelque
chose qui se mange donc ça le paysage
agricole qu'on a organisé aujourd'hui ne
convient pas à une raréfaction
significative de l'approvisionnement
énergétique refaire tout ca c 40 ans et
ses quelques milliers alors je ne sais
pas si c'est 4000 8000 ou dix mille
milliards d'euros mais pour moi c'est
une très bonne nouvelle ça veut dire
qu'on a une colonne vertébrale autour de
laquelle il doit nécessairement y avoir
le même consensus politique que pour le
fait d'avoir des caisses de retraite
sinon s'en sortira jamais et il faut que
vos divergences s'exprime à la marge sur
des petites manières des petits machins
concernant la gestion du problème voilà
un peu plus de marcher ici un peu plus
d'état voilà mais si ça va au delà de ça
ça marchera pas ça ne marchera pas donc
à un moment on a besoin de quelque chose
qui ressemble à une union nationale
sinon on va vers le bazar pour tous
extrêmement bien partagée mais je ne
suis pas sûr que vous ayez été élu
député pour vous occuper de ce genre de
choses en ce qui concerne le nucléaire
où là aussi énormément de questions ont
été posées
alors la réponse courte c'est que je
pense que c'est une bien meilleure idée
qu'une mauvaise dit autrement la phrase
exacte que j'ai envie d'utiliser ces
quinze jours oui le nucléaire est vite
beaucoup plus d'inconvénients qu'il n'en
crée
il ancre est absolument certain je vous
ai dit tout à l'heure les énergies
propres ça n'existe pas pas plus pop je
suis pas sûr
je suis pas sûr parce que c'est pas lui
cirer les pompes on trouve aujourd'hui
allez je vais un peu le taquiner au sein
du parti vert un certain nombre de gens
qui tête à tête entre la poire et le
fromage quand personne ne les écoute à
la limite si avec ça comme sujet de
dissension où il y aurait bon il va bien
on met ça dans un coin et on en parle
plus donc
j'avais tort il faut les écouter
vous avez tort il faut les écouter e le
hc pas et
donc le donc j'insiste un sacré des
inconvénients ça en crée moins que les
inconvénients que cela permet d'éviter
voilà c'est une affaire d'arbitrage
alors sur toute la partie technique
combien de mort à tchernobyl convient de
déchets etc je vous renvoie tous les
écrits qui a sur mon site vous avez une
avalanche de chiffres toutes les
méthodes et les sourcils sont donc comme
ça vous pourrez voir pourquoi je pense
ceci est pas cela
en ce qui concerne ya une question aussi
fondamentale qui a été posée en avant
qui est celle des besoins et on m'a
attaqué au début des questions sur
vous dites qu'il n'ya pas de précarité
etc alors j'insiste encore une fois il
ya les faits et le ressenti des faits ce
qui compte dans le bulletin de vote
c'est le ressenti des feuilles ce qui
compte pour le physicien c'est l'effet
donc c'est pas parce que le ressenti des
faits est totalement distincts des faits
que pour autant les faits ne sont pas
valides à l'époque de la france d'en bas
j'avais fait l'expérience je ne
connaissais personne appartenant à la
france d'en haut donc toute personne
considéré que la france d'en bas c'était
lui plus tout ce qu'ils soient en
dessous ça marche extrêmement bien il ya
une autre boutade que je tiens mon
associé qui est la définition du minimum
vital c'est quelle que soit la personne
à qui vous posez la question c'est ce
que je gagne + 10 % alors ce que je vous
dis là c'est de manière provocante
quelque chose que tocqueville avait
extrêmement bien expliqué dans ses
ouvrages sur la démocratie c'est que la
démocratie nous rendra rouspéteur est
perpétuellement insatisfait de notre
sort puisque comme les chances sur la
ligne de départ sont censés être les
mêmes pour tous si quelqu'un est devant
vous à la ligne d'arrivée c'est pas
juste donc le grand problème c'est qu'il
va falloir faire avec ça et en france 60
1000 kilowatts heure par personne et par
an parce que c'est ça qu'on consomme ces
600 esclaves par personne
l'espérance de vie à la naissance en
france aujourd'hui 75 ans l'espérance de
vie à la naissance en france dans les
campagnes à deux siècles 25 ans donc qui
est pauvre donc la question elle est
tout à fait central en termes de
ressenti et d'équité alors ça vous avez
100% raison en termes de réalité
physique je redis même ce qu'on appelle
modestes devront prendre leur part à
l'effort et je la seule façon que je
vois de l'heure de les faire prendre par
les forces et de leur donner un boulot
et de leur donner une perspective sinon
ça marchera pas sinon ça sera les meutes
le est par contre je pense que s'ils ont
un boulot et une perspective et de la
fierté on peut discuter
question de la fiscalité qui a été posée
aussi sur la taxe carbone or la taxe
carbone à un principe très simple je
taxe plus l'énergie jeu des taxes le
travail c'est très simple le travail ne
fait pas de changement climatique et il
permet de résoudre le chômage le carbone
et importer fout en l'air la balance
commerciale et font en l'air le climat
je déplace la fiscalité c'est aussi
simple que ça il s'agit pas d'en faire
quelque chose de punitif il s'agit d'en
faire de quelque chose qui guide qui dit
alors bah oui c'est exactement comme un
élève vous lui dites pas que en une
semaine après six ans il doit être
capable de rentrer dans une école
d'ingénieurs lui qu'il a 20 ans pour ça
donc le lacet exactement par ou pour
apprendre un métier plus généralement là
c'est exactement pareil il s'agit de
donner un cadre et une vie billy t il se
trouve que mon boulot consiste à essayer
de soutirer à des gens qui n'ont pas
très envie de l'argent pour réfléchir à
leur avenir ils s'appellent les
affreuses industriels que fait un
affreux industriel ou un affreux
gestionnaire d'entreprise quand il à
réfléchir à l'avenir il regarde où sont
les certitudes dans l'avenir qu'on lui
propose et si dans les certitudes il
n'ya pas le fait que l'énergie qu'il
consomme va lui coûter de plus en plus
cher il ne fait pas les investissements
correspondants or l'énergie vous l'avez
vu tout à l'heure c'est le sens de
systèmes qui sont extrêmement rigides
qui sont extrêmement rigides donc ça le
problème énergétique et ça a été dit
aussi se résout par les investissements
essentiellement c'est monstrueusement
capitalistique de faire de l'efficacité
énergétique monstrueusement
capitalistique il faut changer des
procédés industriels il faut changer des
bâtiments il faut changer les
infrastructures de transport il n'y a
rien de plus que changer les bateaux ya
rien de plus capitalistiques que
l'efficacité énergétique donc si on ne
donne hors désinvestissements
vous avez besoin de visibilité pour
avoir envie de les faire donc si on ne
donne pas un cadre de visibilité à
l'économie sur le prix sur les
externalités de l'inconvénient et ça
renvoie à la finitude du monde faut
mettre ça sous forme d'externalités dans
l'économie mais ça fait pas un projet de
société c'est un outil si on ne donne
pas un prix aux externalités dans lequel
industrielle de la visibilité à ce
moment il reste assis sur sa chaise il
reste assis sur sa chaise et c'est très
exactement pareil pour les particuliers
regardez la manière dont le différentiel
essence gazole à déformer le parc
automobile en france en trente ou
quarante ans ça joue un rôle majeur à
long terme ce genre de signaux ça joue
un rôle à court terme jamais à long
terme ça joue un rôle évidemment c'est
toute la difficulté du métier que vous
faites vous êtes jugés sur des résultats
à trois ans quand le remède que vous
proposez vos ans proposé par an produira
c'est pour ça que je disais si on ne
compte pas dans la population des
consensus sur ce genre de sujet qui
dépasse les clivages partisans on aura
le bordel excusez moi on aura le bordel
alors dans la dernière chose qu'il a va
pas faire plaisir à notre ami baupin
c'est la question du nucléaire
je pense que si on veut que la
population achète une vision à long
terme et que si le milieu économique
hachette qu'on veut qu'il aimait qu'ils
achètent on peut pas être incohérent
donc on peut pas dire gérard cheese et
les nuisances comme ça puis finalement
maintenant je vais les traiter comme ça
donc ou bien on se dit la question de la
dépendance de l'économie européenne aux
combustibles fossiles et du changement
climatique c'est supra par rapport aux
nuits et alors on prend tout ce qui
permet de virer les énergies fossiles
tout nucléaire compris ou bien on dit
pour le moment là on a sorti un chiffre
d'un chapeau parce que 50 % comme ça ça
faisait bien et puis 2025 ça faisait
bien parce que entre nous soit dit s'est
sorti d'un chapeau ce chiffre est à ce
moment et à ce moment pas bon et sarkozy
en a sorti d'autres donc encore une fois
envahi qu'on va on va équilibrer les
mais le l'un comme l'autre ont été
victimes d'illusions c'est pas du
mensonge c'est de l'illusion c'est très
différent
le mensonge en a aussi mais là en
l'occurrence pour moi c'est c'est pire
que ça quelque part c'est de l'illusion
et donc le parce qu'il ya des grands
hommes d'état qui ont menti à des
moments où il pensait que c'était très
utile pour la population avec une vision
de long terme donc donc rejeter de vous
choquer en vous disant le mensonge bien
utilisé peut-être qu'il ya des moments
où c'est très salutaire mais là il
s'agit pas de mensonge il s'agit
d'illusions encore une fois c'est très
différent
et donc si on dit dans cette affaire
qu'on se jette résolument dans le fait
d'être de mettre en place une société
qui sait fonctionner avec moins de
combustibles fossiles d'abord je pense
que le sujet du nucléaire devient un
sujet secondaire il faut quand même
savoir qu'en grande bretagne après
fukushima
l'acceptance du nucléaire a augmenté
elle est plus forte aujourd'hui qu'elle
ne l'était avant fukushima chez les
suédois elle n'a pas changé donc
arrêtons de regarder le nombril y'a pas
que nous dans cette histoire donc si on
dit on a vraiment
en iran je suis pas partisan vraiment
mais encore une fois il ya des tas de
trucs non médias d'état je suis très
partisans d'avoir un couteau pour couper
mon vittek et je suis pas partisan de
l'avoir pour tuer quelqu'un donc le la
question de savoir si un truc est
nécessairement blanc ou noir vous savez
très bien que c'est un faux débat
donc le genre revient à ce que je disais
le
à partir du moment où on dit c'est ça
notre projet de long terme je pense que
c'est si on arrive à entraîner l'europe
la france a encore du poids dans la dans
la structuration du destin européen je
pense que si on arrive à entraîner
l'europe dans une voie qui est on
invente l'économie en 40 ans pendant une
semaine on invente l'économie qui permet
d'avoir des aspirations sociales et
d'avoir de l'espoir pour l'avenir avec
de moins en moins de combustibles
fossiles je pense que c'est en faisant
ça puisque nous sommes des animaux
mimétique qu'on a le maximum de chances
d'entraîner le reste du monde dans
l'action dit autrement ça fait 20 ans
qu'on se des chiens de faïence parce que
personne ne sait comment faire les
premiers qui font ils emporteront le
morceau premier qui font cette prime a
pris ma l'agresseur le primat
l'assaillant pour comment il faut dire
mais c'est le premier qui fait qu'en
portera le morceau l'europe a une raison
excellente pour faire qui n'a rien à
voir avec le climat je le redis c'est
que si on reste sur la ligne de pente en
ce qui concerne les combustibles
fossiles on enchaînera des récessions en
étant complètement désemparé face à ce
qui nous arrivera voilà ce qu'ils
veulent voilà ce qui va se produire donc
les le bazar dans les banlieues c'est
que le début si on si on reste sur la
ligne de pente et encore une fois c'est
pas critiquer le président qu'on vient
d'élire trois sont là pour cinq ans on
va bosser avec lui
c'est de bien se rendre compte de la
marge de manoeuvre et de terrain de jeu
qui est aujourd'hui une autre et de ce
qu'on a le droit de faire dans ce
terrain de jeu pour avoir de l'espoir et
de ce qui est vouée à l'échec d'entrée
de jeu et je suis tout à fait d'accord
je suis très content d'avoir entendu et
c'est pas parce que
on sait déjà parlé avant avec la
remarque d'edouard philippe je pense que
ce truc là c'est voici loustallot vous
stimulez pas du tout vous abattre pense
que ça doit vous stimuler et pas du tout
vous abattre par contre je pense que le
temps presse on l'a déjà dit et je pense
qu'il est donc extrêmement urgent
d'avoir quelque chose qui commence à
être un peu sérieux sur la manière dont
on fait un projet politique désirable
dans ce genre d'univers
pense que c'est urgent
moi je viens vous y aider
oui alors les énergies renouvelables
j'ai pas ggg j'ai été un peu taquin sur
les sur une chose mais qui correspond
encore une fois ou fait je vais vous
donner un exemple à la suite du grenelle
on aurait dit le truc intéressant s'est
déployée les poêles à bois je redis très
bien on a dit on va investir dans les
panneaux solaires photovoltaïques
c'est la dernière des conneries qu'il
fallait faire donc je suis pas contre
les énergies renouvelables je suis
contre la méthode sentimentale de
gestion d'un sujet sérieux à partir du
moment où le sujet est majeur on ne gère
pas que des méthodes sentimental moi si
j'ai un sujet majeur dans ma boîte je
vais jamais gérer ça avec des méthodes
sentimentale sinon je suis sûr de couler
il ya un pays qui est remarquable en
matière d'énergies renouvelables qui
s'appelle la suède la suède n'a
quasiment pas de combustibles fossiles
dans son industrie lourde quasiment pas
je vous rappelle soit dit en passant que
la suède consomme autant d'électricité
nucléaire par personne que la france
vous le saviez ça
autant d'électricité nucléaire par
personne que la france en suède et ils
ont sauf erreur de ma part une
réputation parfaitement écolo ou
vénitien donc la suède consomment deux
fois plus d'électricité que la france
par personne moitié hydraulique moitié
du clae r l'industrie lourde utilise
essentiellement de l'électricité
décarbonés et du bois ils ont une ils
ont une consommation de gaz et de
charbon en suède qui est quasi nulle et
la totalité du chauffage est assuré avec
des réseaux de chaleur au bois mais ils
ont trois cent cinquante mille
kilomètres carrés de pays pour 9
millions d'habitants couvert à 70 % de
forêts et et est la clé du succès pour
les énergies renouvelables elle va être
là toujours la clé du succès pour les
énergies renouvelables c'est beaucoup de
montagne beaucoup d'espacé pour faire
pousser quelque chose sinon compliqué
une des énergies renouvelables à mon
avis très intéressante à regarder pour
les européens c'est ce qui se passe dans
le désert où il ya plein de soleil et
pas beaucoup de monde à emmerder et au
lieu de dépenser 100 ou 150 milliards
d'euros dans la cspe pour déployer du
photovoltaïque en france on aurait fait
un grand projet industriel avec ça pour
se mettre d'accord avec les marocains
les algériens en du gazon qui s'en
foutent et les tunisiens et les libyens
aujourd'hui on aurait pris pied sur
quelque chose où on était sûr de donner
du boulot aux ouvriers français pour
développer des technologies qui seront
peut être extrêmement utile dans tout
l'est dans toute la bande tropicale à
l'avenir donc voilà je suis pas du tout
contre les énergies renouvelables je
suis un grand partisan des énergies
renouvelables gérer avec des méthodes
sérieuse
je suis désolé c'est beaucoup plus
sérieux que le [ __ ]
1 liberté qui serait beaucoup plus
sérieux que desertec
vient écouter
les espagnols aujourd'hui qu'ils sont en
train de trouver la potion économique
pas très sympathiques ils ont plein de
soleil dans le sud est à mon avis allait
faire des choses intelligentes dans le
solaire à concentration avec les
espagnols aujourd'hui c'est bien mieux
que de faire du père et en france
voila voila du photovoltaïque en france
voilà donc la question c'est par dont
l'éolien en france n'a pas beaucoup
d'intérêt l'éolien a de l'intérêt dans
les pays qui ont des centrales à charbon
et qu'ils souhaitent consommer un peu
moins de charbon
si vous commencez à avoir une diffusion
massive de l'éolien vous avez besoin de
moyens de stockage derrière et là le
coût du mégawattheure éolien stocker
restituer dans une steppe que vous
auriez créé pour l'occasion ils se
baladent quelque part entre 200 et 400
euros
alors c'est pas nécessairement une
mauvaise chose parce que contrairement à
ce que vous pouvez penser une hausse du
prix de l'énergie moi je m'en fous si
c'est de l'art entre distribué
nationalement d'accord je m'en fous ce
qu'ils n'ont mais c'est ça qu'il faut
que ce soit alors par ailleurs un autre
truc j'ai pas eu le temps de vous
présenter aujourd'hui mais une autre est
de 3 qui se trouve sur mon site montre
et ça c'est peut-être le mot de la fin
que quand vous déplacer une énergie
produite nationalement exemple nucléaire
vers une autre énergie produite
nationalement exemple l'éolien si vous
payez les gens la même chose dans les
deux cas de figure globalement on ne
crée pas d'emplois c'est perturbant il
ya une règle de trois qui permet de le
montrer
merci à jean marc jancovici
pour son intervention est la réponse à
ces questions est ce débat nourri et je
l'espère fructueux merci beaucoup